you've got picture that [ __ ] monkeys
into this morning for breakfast
what's that who sent you those type of
pictures anymore what but oh that that
the picture you sent me yeah for that
they're girls
lovely private parts oh that's the best
name for a vagina monkey I send them to
everybody to presidents of corporations
cops on Monday happy Monday everybody's
days a lot better
uh start the damn the right foot
specially put presidents and
corporations people that you imagine if
you had to work in a [ __ ] office for
your whole life as old as we are now if
we were in an office since the time we
were like 23 24 years old right at
school just everyday button-down try not
to say anything that's gonna get you in
trouble just trying to [ __ ] make it
to five o'clock and then immediately go
to a bar and talk [ __ ] with your friends
and then do it all over again on Monday
I time it so I know you're in a meeting
I know that you're in a meeting with
eight white dudes a real serious about
you know numbers have to be out
statistics and I'll sign your phone
rings you [ __ ] open it up it's a
picture with woman's vagina breaks up
the hormonal I think God Joey Diaz
exists because he understands what I'm
going through
that's tough that's tough corner sales
meetings I used to go to sales meetings
and they talk about don't you know what
the Anthony Robbins are things did you
well I was a burglar and what the
engineer Robin CPS better burger know
and I ended up kidnapping a [ __ ]
he said I walked on the polls I was all
in with Anthony Robbins you know those
really because I worked for a Subaru
dealerships or Subaru paid for you to go
to Anthony Robbins seminars so they
would give me like three bills for the
day for per diem I would go to Denver
and do the Anthony Robbins seminar do it
you should be a Subaru spokesperson
who's more loyal to Subaru than you
nobody he [ __ ] loves Subarus love him
love him I just cannot because he lived
in Boulder I lived in Aspen
yes and I saw vans I saw every type of
high level costs been around and you
just lose control
and I give a lose control on Colorado I
didn't but I did respond for a bunch of
times yeah it wasn't fun it's not
whenever you're driving in so it's
touch-and-go
you could get patches of ice and in
Colorado at night you got a thing called
black ice and you know I remember being
I worked at the Crestwood I was security
and I had to pick people up at the
airport at night and I [ __ ] did
everything I could to get out of that
job because when I was in a van with
people doing the speed limit
no alcohol you know me I just hit black
ice and the thing started spinning and
you don't know where you're gonna land
you have no idea I was a you acquire it
so you guys wire and I were on the way
to the airport in Ohio and we cross over
a bridge and bridges where you get it
because there's no ground underneath it
so things freeze quicker we went over
this bridge just we just got lucky
nothing happened we both went alright
you know it stopped where we were facing
the wrong way but there was no one on
the road cuz it was early we were headed
back to the airport and we just got
packed in wine and just like okay I
remember this I remember this like all
the sudden you got no power you know I
love German technology I love to look a
lot of sport cars and everything like
that but one I there's been nights
happen at ten years ago I had a gig in
Irvine and it was raining one of those
January and cot in California just
coming down I mean you couldn't see in
front and cause a bulldog and I'm doing
75 minutes ooh why is a Subaru so good
at that what is the big deal about
Subarus what I first started with like I
had never sold the car before I was a
detailer and I became a French at the
guy at Subaru and he bust my balls every
day's name was Peter Pan dolphin Florida
[Music]
Florida went all the way up to Colorado
to sell cars and he became man and I got
I was properly introduced in those days
they gave you 1,500 bucks the first
month and they trained you for two weeks
on cars I knew nothing about the car
like when you had that car in the axle
fell off you got rid of it because
you're not a car guy you're not gonna
get up on Saturdays and go to the Splore
and find the piece from 1966 come
it just some people have that love that
[ __ ]
Tim Al and Jay Leno Oh Gabriel I love
them for that I don't have that gift so
when I was introduced to the super I'm
like yeah whatever it's just another
[ __ ] car and then I saw snowstorms
and I saw how people reacted to superoes
in Boulder it's either Subaru or a
[ __ ] 4runner yeah that's it I'm sorry
I knew that said something you know once
the snow drops that September snowstorm
it's super-super was the first car that
has an engine sideways the engine isn't
in like usual cause that was the secret
about Subaru engine side it's it's I've
seen a few engines like that what do
they call that in line is something like
now in line is straight right that's
like a BMW they have solid word for it I
have it's super technology started there
and then when I started selling Subarus
and had a GL ten I was really impressed
with because what it like let you do is
if you went up if you won up Lee Hill
Road okay and you made the left to go
down into your property and there was
snow you could press a button and the
shock absorbers would fill up and your
car would rise above C to go through the
snow so all those little things the only
night I had that way back then 1988-89
the GL pens the only knock Subaru had
was that if you had a stick you couldn't
keep your hand on it you couldn't keep
your handling right so if I'm driving a
stick boom I'm a woman - right I'm
injury I got a kept my hand off it I
could only the clutch cable that was the
only knock they had so the question
would break it would break if you kept
your hand huh I had one of those break
on me once yes so you have to go one
then two then three then four I had to
actually break him twice once I got
stuck in second gear and I managed to
drive to a parking lot and get towed
that was in I had a 2005 or something
like that
2004 2005 Porsche they just kept
breaking and the thing that kept
breaking was that that thing with the
clutch and also the fuel pump
see I was a GL 10 sedan I'm talking
about the wagon the doodle up wagon was
just a brilliant automobile and then I
started selling Toyotas those things are
still on the road just on the road guys
and this is what I'm saying about the
American bow I like the Subaru because I
respect what they do with the American
dollar
well they do they give you $1 worth for
$1 all right
they really do for the American who's
really looking for a [ __ ] car to last
I've gone in to Douglas Toyota and have
seen trucks with a half of a million
miles on it I'll tell you a truck that
says a lot
hmm when you're an American and you're a
construction guy you know you're putting
them bids in bah-bah-bah do you know
Matt Farah smoking tire do you know that
- no he's a big fan of yours he loves
comedy he's got this great YouTube
channel it's all about cars and they had
a car a Lexus that they took - a million
miles he had a million mile Lexus now
who makes life's at the end of the day
Oh des what the [ __ ] could we do that's
what I'm saying
so when I had three Lexuses over the
course of my life never had a single
problem zero problems they just they
just work didn't always work they just
work all cars are so amazing now it's
like the the the bar is set so high that
if you just get like us like if you get
a Mustang GT just a Mustang GT today
which is like very reasonable like I
think a Ford Mustang GT tell me how much
one of those [ __ ] things cost but
it's got performance that you couldn't
even imagine 20 years ago and it's
probably under $50,000 it's probably 40
grand how much of those 26 26 26 hours
is that for the regular Mustang or the
GT I say it is my tectum GT but it says
regular home okay so that's where I
think the regular one might have a
six-cylinder I'm not sure I think they
still do that so I might be wrong about
that premium fastback starts at 39 okay
the and that's the one with the v8 right
that's the coyote v8 it's a 5-liter v8
[ __ ] rip wicked powerful like 460
horsepower I mean the power that you get
with 40,000 45,000 dollars today it's
just insane they keep getting better and
better and better it's like where are
they gonna code these well
and the leases are great the lease is a
great delete the deals they're giving me
now I mean a buddy of mine just bought a
Connie how to point half whatever
interest rate oh you know four point I
have mediocre credit it's a time to buy
a car yeah yeah whatever the [ __ ] you
want Wow cars a good dog that's that
yeah it's like you can't make a shitty
car anymore like America went through a
time period we just made dog [ __ ] cars
and everybody knew that they broke and
everybody was like looking buy American
cars you you're gonna buy something that
it's gonna cost the same amount but it's
not gonna last as long and the Japanese
just took the Germans they just took
over it doesn't open then Lee Iacocca
brought it back with the cake off you
know it's the most hilarious country
that's the cars my people the Italian a
single car that's reliable when we had
the conversation about my buddy who had
the the Italian car he went he went
crazy I'm gonna keep it in my roots the
car is still in the garage
bro rusty [ __ ] the Bugatti or
whatever the [ __ ] Perry the new ones you
can drive like a new one they're
actually reliable for two weeks no no no
no the new ones apparently it's like
everything else they got to a point
where they just had to have better yes I
do de triumph we grew up on the triumphs
the thing by Volkswagen
I don't remember things by Volkswagen
was that their little van thing it was a
little van thing that that they're very
there's like 10 left if you got a thing
somebody'll give you a million dollars
really they had a Subaru made a car
called the JA that's it
that's the thing Subaru made a car
called adjusted three cylinder just a
beat just to compete with the Hyundai
when the Hyundai came out with the mutt
'mobile in 87 my Hyundai changed a game
and they came out with the Istana what
I'm like a little four-door car is 160
you know 150 down 150 a month busted the
car industry Subaru yeah Pete everybody
had to drop those tin cans just to
compete those there was a lot of people
driving those Hyundai's when they first
came out I thought it was so cheaper but
buddy of my god 50 150 a month
yeah all day long a buddy of mine called
Monday that I used to drive deliver
papers with then he was telling me he's
like look look these [ __ ] Koreans man
when they get into something they know
what they're doing
like if they're gonna jump into the car
market that that's a disciplined group
of people if they're gonna jump into the
car market they're gonna make a badass
car whoa listen and they're very
reliable Mitsubishi for example
Mitsubishi people hate Mitsubishi
American why the hate myths of issue
because Mitsubishi made the parts that
were in the magnets that the American is
one up against some World War two oh
really so if you try to sell a [ __ ]
those those guys are all gone
knocking that rest in peace but when you
sold the car to a guy that did the
reading I like there was certain
Chrysler's that had Mitsubishi parts
Ford had Mitsubishi parts on it because
mr. B she's like the greatest biggest
thing of car parts buses everybody has
Mitsubishi parts on that car something
belongs to Mitsubishi so if you had a
Mitsubishi you're a bad person
no no no no so when most some Americans
old school veterans you know those guys
that wear the jackets with the act with
them when they come to see a car if you
show them the Chrysler a certain type of
Chrysler they go nah they got a
Mitsubishi [ __ ] can well tailpipe
that makes sense because that's how
pissed off they were about because the
mag's would shoot down the Americans or
somebody with something I get historic
thing but that Mitsubishi got into the
business
Mitsubishi but still along unlike the
eighties the late eighties they came out
with that [ __ ] car the Eclipse hmm
remember the Eclipse I remember that
yeah a little [ __ ] car I had a
Mitsubishi at one point I have story on
every day yeah because they were cheap
you know you go until you go into Toyota
plans to buy your money you didn't speak
to that dodge used to sell their version
of the story on it was the conquest
Dodge had the conquest TSI and it was
their version of the star and it was the
same car it was one of the rare times in
history where two car companies have the
exact same car the exact same car one
was the conch
was a story on that was it yes that red
one right looks exactly like my buddy
Jimmy to tell you yep my buddy Jimmy had
one exactly like that when we were like
21 this is why it's very hard for a guy
like me to fall for fans especially for
cars because I've seen a lot of fan I
remember Suzuki Samurai mm-hmm how many
[ __ ] killed this is uki samurai
was like the scooter you know these
jerk-offs at the school just today
thinking that that cool huh does the
zookie samurai came around and it
started tipping over
things started tipping over
but again take corners with the one
feels like a sports car thing weighed 8
pounds
I had a friend's tipping them over they
were made of [ __ ] ten and then one
goofy down you know 150 a month and for
[ __ ] an extra 25 hours that a guy
with a fan because you would die in
these things people would die what the
[ __ ] yeah they sell these in the Studio
City
what is it it's a electric car that's
like a one-seater it's a three wheel
one-seater Electra meccanica I don't
have to say it I think that's it Electra
dad it's crazy and it's a one-person car
yeah it's a bro it doubles as a casket
that's what's great about that [ __ ]
car that your family saves 10 G's buy a
casket they just bury in that [ __ ]
thing but if you think about if you have
to get around everywhere it's just you
most days and something like this is
cheap what is the difference between
being in that and being in a big truck
where all that [ __ ] empty [ __ ]
thing you ever drive past one of these
idiots and you had a light and you
actually look at them and you're like
you're in his mind he's thinking he's
the coolest guy in the [ __ ] world
that guy thinks he's [ __ ] Ricky
Gervais that's actually a cool looking
one
look at that fronts good hood scoop Joe
that's a casket light no it's a hood
scoop is that their high beams looks
like a headlights but I think that's
actually a real hood scoop for some
strange lasting piece over it yeah what
is that is that clear plastic over it
could be because it's inside but I don't
know I'm so crazy that's like the rx-7
the arcs
was a casket for two was it remember the
Mazda ah yeah I [ __ ] hated that car
you know why that's why because I was
coming home on January 1st and I was one
of the first people on the site and I
was I don't know I don't want to sad and
I was tripping on something I was on
some type of drug but I wasn't over the
hill I was still alert and we were like
maybe the third car there and it was a
Mazda then hit a pole
head-on and it was split down the middle
all the way to the windshield and I
could hear the girl yelling oh my god
and we were there the fire department
came ambulance a couple heroes came out
he was dead on arrival
they saw the car and that's why I don't
like those little cars their caskets
that's the caskets hmm in those days and
after that I'd never gotten to her
except my buddy the devil had an rx-7
were they the ones with the rotary
engine I don't know as Mazda has there's
a sports car company that uniquely has a
rotary engine it's a different kind of
engine it's not like cylinders said it
is Mazda yeah they got a different kind
of engine to touch my car more modern
Mazdas like mm maybe no no it was like
90s like before okay it was before I
moved to California see look at that
thing
that's how the engine works instead of
having a bunch of Pistons it's got this
big [ __ ] thing in the middle of it
like I wish I understood engines to know
why this is that different engines have
yeah real car people must be going crazy
I'm sorry I don't know [ __ ] so we're
watching this video that says Mazda rx-7
rotary engine how it works and it's
describing how it works it's a very
strange video were you watching this
thing rolling around inside of an oval
looks like a big oval engine container
it's very different but it's very fast
it was the one that this guy had
guess like I'm saying I'm think it's 93
or something like that it was really
fast
and it really handled really well too
but it was a very light car these things
are weird when like rotary engine that's
weird like how come nobody else adopted
that just but it looks like a badass
watch you know see I didn't have a car
education but by selling cars and
Boulder I learned a lot now I forget
that stuff I'm not gonna lie there
because the the level of intelligence in
Boulder from the University when they
would come in the end I'm a boulder
let's at the end of the day University
Colorado you don't want to be an
astronaut you know that is that where
does like that's that's heavy-duty
Boulder they have like a whole thing
back there so those people move into
town between them and the Japanese that
move there they come to Subaru and they
ask very intelligent questions
completely different than a guy like you
me or Jamie will ask the same weird um
yes compared to what they will compared
to what they'd ask like what kind of
questions no velocity this that this and
I'd have to find these answers for them
because they were like astronauts I'd
have to go in there was no computers in
any [ __ ] ate like that I could go on
so I have to go on a brochure and really
go into it and then they take the
calculator out like there is type of
people so that's why I remember learning
as much as I could because there was so
intelligent when they'd come over
specially the Japanese guys they
couldn't speak that good English but
they would look at cause what's this
what's the wait that's what's really
amazing if you stop and think about the
creation of cars and how they've evolved
they keep getting better for a long time
they did it without the internet a long
time well some of them up the greatest
cars ever created pre-internet
you know there's just think about all
the various forms of sports cars and
911s all those different Corvettes that
came out all that [ __ ] was before the
internet they were just looking at each
other's pictures and
looking at magazines and everyone was
competing against each other to have the
best handling car the best looking car
best fuel efficiency things kept
shifting over the years like for 10
years in America they didn't make
anything good and for 10 years what
would what would you use the years from
American muscle cars when I say anything
good I mean like something that like a
muscle car lover other than the Trans Am
the Trans Am is the exception to the
rule
Trans Am they made some you know those
smoking the Bandit cars that people to
this day still want that was in the 70s
but from the 1960s like say 65 ish to
like 70 America couldn't be touched
those muscle cars were insane they just
kept pumping out cooler and cooler
shapes
what did classic driver drove he drove a
1968 fastback Mustang got a bad mother
phone yeah how bad a [ __ ] well
it's a beautiful car the design is put
the back end of the 68 Mustang is one of
the most underrated forms in all of
automotive design that's a 68 Shelby
that's different that's a gt500 is a
totally different shape the Shelby had a
completely different set of rear
taillights they had altered quite a bit
about the Shelby like the way it looks
in the front end as well there's regular
68 Mustang it just has this beautiful
like contoured rear end look at that
look at that that green car that is
that's like a real modern looking like
updated version of it real pretty you
know with a phenomenal deep green paint
job but look how good that rear looks
that's what he drove that's what he
drove [ __ ] look at that that is
Americana baby look at the tail end of
that [ __ ] vehicle man with the chrome
and the chrome bumpers and the red
headlights and the black behind look at
that [ __ ] car man no seat belt
well they had those ones around your
waist you like in the back you know
waking up but no there's no seat belt
about you bounced around like [ __ ]
rock back how many horsepower it's not
that much not that much man of a really
powerful car back then had like 350
horsepower like let's find out what was
the 1968 gt500 that was their mo
powerful one I wanna I'm gonna imagine
this had like 400 horsepower say 1968
just Shelby GT 500 horsepower 1968
Shelby GT because that was their what
they would do is they take it to Carroll
Shelby caliber we take the regular
Mustang just juice it the [ __ ] up more
power better handling better looks we're
on it perfect yeah now who were they
competing with like what was this is
Ford right yeah they were competing
against the Camaro at this point because
they made a garbage the car in the cold
back sort of the court that was like a
little bit of a different category
because it was a pure sports car where
this car had back seats so that's a 400
horsepower it's so to compare to the
Mustang of today the regular GT forget
about the new one they have a new gt500
that has like 760 horsepower the new
gt500 goes zero to 60 in like three
seconds it's a monstrous one where
they're making for that movie that just
came out that was it the Ford verse
Ferrari Oh
for the moment I don't know I think it
was that about race car I didn't see it
was about it was Shelby it was him
making that car I think like they had oh
really make it or two days demand [ __ ]
I didn't see well probably for the movie
they got juice that up right I don't
know the I told I thought they were race
cars though I didn't think they were
like these kind of cars it's like a GT
car
hey I don't know oh yeah this is the
gt500 maybe that's what that was for
yeah I think it's not even the gt500 I
think it's the gt40
which was their race car I think it's
because it's I'm pretty sure I saw in
the I didn't see the move not you - no I
think - aw I think it's a different GT I
think it's their actual racecar racecar
but the new one this Shelby has a new
gt500 it's a ridiculous car it's faster
around tracks than the new Corvette they
have a new Corvette this crazy rear
engined meet mid-engined rather
Corvettes the newest Corvette it's the
best Corvette ever and this gt500 is
even faster than that it's bonkers right
gt40 yeah it's a different kind of car
that's the car that's only for the
racetrack these guys these you're beat
you could buy a Shelby gt500 today you
walk out of a dealer showroom hi
hi do you know how to drive yes sir
here's my license like you don't have to
hardly know [ __ ] and they'll let you
just drive home and one of the most
preposterous automobiles ever offered to
man you just go pretty to a Ford
dealership and if you have the I'm gonna
say a Shelby gt500 a $80,000 how much
does that cost but a brand new Shelby
gt500 we really don't feel it yet
already already okay how much one else
cost 72 nine that's crazy
760 horsepower so for 72 73 thousand
dollars you can buy a car that is so
fast if you if you really can know that
there's a difference between the speed
of that and then the next car after that
the next car that's more powerful you
really should be in jail LCD
oh it's dope is flaunting cluster yeah
well a lot of cars are doing that now
because they can get so much more
information in front of you instead of
just the standard gauges but do there's
still something about them standard
gauges see that Mustang electric car yes
not bad it's not bad at all it's like a
fat Mustang right yeah it's interesting
right they're using the Mustang name for
other [ __ ] now that's controversial that
could cause a problem why not just come
up with another name that's not a
Mustang you know that's not a Mustang
that's an SUV yeah what about it makes
it a Mustang if it's alright why you'd
like that they're talking about doing
that with Corvette - the Corvette could
branch off and become a brand like
Cadillac is you know Cadillac is a brand
it's you know it's synonymous with
luxury you think of Cadillacs but it's a
GM car and if they decide to take the
Corvette model and just make it a brand
and so have core dope SUVs like fast
racy SUVs fast racy four-door sedans
whatever sells cars man cuz did you see
that Tesla's now valued at as much as GM
and Ford together combined yeah whoops
guys [ __ ] dummies he's a super cheap
yes just back off it's hilarious right
yeah so going up today like God makes
amazing cars he makes amazing [ __ ]
cars we're talking about Elon Musk Tesla
is worth more today than what is it
what's the stock Yemen for it's like
it's over 500 now but like the market
value is their combined yeah and
everybody was saying it was gonna fall
apart I think it's a beautiful car guys
but I got to give more time especially
the self-driving [ __ ] my brother has
it's beautiful he's got the electronic
one it was one login which one who I
don't know yeah that's gorgeous but he
was telling me to go to San Diego he's
gonna stop in Commerce City yep and plug
it in for 20 minutes and sit there like
a bump on a log
yep you do you know there's just so many
different charging places I took an uber
a couple weeks ago I got into a car that
was just amazing that blew me away a
[ __ ] Honda Accord Hybrid well they're
making everything Accord is that they
make some nicer corner now this car even
listen you get in the Honda you get
Toyota sometimes I'll tell you it as
much but uh Mitsubishi what's the other
one
Hyundai when you close the door there's
a lightness in the metal that's where
you see the you know there's a light
that's like to be close a certain way
when I get in here [ __ ] Porsche and I
close it that's that makes a certain
noise you know it's yes think noise
we've you uh you never been in my little
tiny one
I got a 1993 964 it's a real light car
but the metal in it is so much thicker
it this doors like trunk when you close
the door
chunk like you could feel the weight to
it you feel when you tap the fenders to
there's no give it's a different
structure totally different so I was
blown away by the Honda Accord Hybrid
you know what we're playing paying for
jam and it's just a great little car
look another couple different options I
was in Huntington Beach you're thinking
about going away from Subaru and adding
something to my collection just because
I've always said you need a Cadillac
you should be a Cadillac man - he gave
me a ride last week I was in Huntington
Beach I took the special uber uber spell
and it was that Cadillac and he told me
exactly how he got it what the scam is
with them how to do it he has he hasn't
had a problem the battery died and
that's the that's their main not the
battery's time one day you wake up I go
to the commies alright I'll [ __ ] choke
it you're wrong no joke I get in my
Subaru the batteries never dead I wonder
if they're more reliable now I don't
know anything about them I've never
owned one but I've rented a ton of
[ __ ] gorgeous that's a good car and
when you submit what model is that it's
yes that's the CTS ESV is that whoa
that's a beautiful [ __ ] car man
look at that front end the design is
just so it's so interesting it's after I
left here the last time over the last
two times a guy reached out and said he
would give me one you need a Cadillac
560 I'm want the lease to roll down take
it Joey I want to see you strolling
around the Cadillac I would love it
bumpin biggie having a lesbian car and
it hurts my feelings like why are you
driving a lesbian car lesbian [ __ ]
Subaru you love a reliable car I respect
that about you I want to get in the car
and started I don't want to be in
service I don't think these things are
unreliable you know I got free service
you know that the warranties they give
you now or [ __ ] you know Volkswagen
which you nobody buys look at that what
is that that's a Cadillac cts-v look at
that [ __ ] car is that the coupe it's
not a four-door it's hard to tell
because the picture is so dark
that's a four-door it's - yeah actually
that little rear window it's not like a
full window wow it's a beautiful car man
they make some killer you know what's a
killer [ __ ] car right now if you want
an SUV a Lincoln Navigator the new one
is insane I wonder what happened in
Lincoln they still in business they only
make the Navigator and then they
one other one or two other luxury coupes
Lincoln which are very nice nice
gorgeous then they went away like they
just well there's this big 10 million of
those palermo drivers and they stopped
production on him so i didn't know what
was going on with lincoln garden i know
they just tapped out
you know what's the [ __ ] is those 1965 s
with the suicide doors come on son you
know I'm never that bold I could not buy
one of those cars you got rolling around
in one of those 1965 Lincoln
Continentals with the suicide doors like
holy [ __ ] Riaan wanna drive dijon
continental see what he drove Jamie you
used to get out open the door sideways
whatever his name was the black beauty
Chrysler Imperial crown a beautiful for
Wow let me see a picture of that 1966
Chrysler look at that thing
we're looking at picture one ladies and
gentlemen it looks like it has machine
guns to poke out of the hood well that
missiles that was the black beauty tell
my god that's hilarious
but I like I always like that's a car
you had a [ __ ] car who made that one
now that's a restomod Green Hornet now
the new one that was the new one with
Seth Rogen right yeah I didn't see that
one no no the one we dropped that one
look at that one
people don't understand we're a little
too young for it but people don't
understand what an impact Bruce Lee had
when he was doing the Green Hornet when
people saw him do martial arts moves the
way he did on screen like people wanted
I mean you have to think about how many
people would watch a TV show back then
like if you had a TV show there's only
like three different things to watch
right like if you had a TV show you had
the entire country watching one of three
things and if you had a big show if The
Green Hornet was the Green Hornet and on
Sunday nights
so was it was like stealing yeah
everyone home you had
you either had lawrence welk on [ __ ]
channel 7 on ABC look at he's p8 you
didn't see this looks like I dropped and
he just traumatized NBC NBC was
traumatized only did 6 episode look how
bad their [ __ ] fight scenes are these
look at these white guys faking punches
oh my god it's hilarious to see like old
school bad TV like fight acting like
well you know the punch didn't hit them
in the hair goes flying it's so weird
especially because we're not playing any
of the volume so we're just watching it
so when you're watching with no volume
you get to really see how preposterous
it is how many how many TV shows that
that guys you know that Spanish dude did
about a thousand episodes of different
TV shows from the late 60s all through
the 70s who isn't I don't know what he's
the guy that was starring right there
right there that guy you know character
actors were like [ __ ] so huge back
then but then Bruce Lee came on Sunday
nights I still remember driving back
from Miami with my family I like being
pissed because I miss Bruce Lee then
they cancelled it you didn't see nothing
about Bruce Lee again bro how long was
it between that and the big movies it
was about a year and a half that come
for movies were mainstream Five Fingers
a death came out no the yeah
Five Fingers at that it was all about
the iron palm technique the guy would
look at you and this pawn would turn
pink and that started with that and then
Fist of Fury came huh but I'm not gonna
lie to you and tell you I went to see
Fist of Fury in the movie theater I
don't remember when Chinese connection
came out that's what changed the
ballgame but see it pisses me off today
you know when I see [ __ ] people with
twenty years old talking about the
impact of Bruce Lee or whatever first
off let's get this straight
Bruce Lee was a tough guy but he wasn't
gonna beat Muhammad Ali that was so
silly he wasn't gonna be Bob Marley he
was
whatever Bruce Lee Bruce Lee meant that
the little guy had hope Bruce Lee gave
the immigrant hope you know that's what
all these guys all we [ __ ] it changed
everybody put a little bounce in the
step he chose martial arts he changed
martial arts but he gave you hope the
movie theaters were packed martial arts
schools were packed black people were
going crazy because nobody sucked it
anymore
you see dolemite yet no I don't know
again you know you gotta watch these
shits if I'm gonna come on the show when
Dolomites do you see it when he's no one
you mean the new way to walk first over
[ __ ] my our boy stole the show our
boy the dudes were you were gonna
[ __ ] MMA Oh whistles oh the [ __ ]
movie okay bad [ __ ] bad
[ __ ]
bad [ __ ] oh you know I'm sick
and tired as people don't walk what
happened to him nothing happened to him
well well well Joe what happened to Dave
Attell David Tao is getting stronger
every weekend what you're looking at
some [ __ ] idiot jumping up and down
on Netflix David Tao is getting stronger
and stronger when you go see Dave Attell
it's like people going crazy right now
about uncut gems [ __ ] Adam Sandler's
been around for 30 years he's got
something for your ass it may not be
goofy jumping up and down and wetting
here but when he did have you seen own
country hurt it's great just go for him
to cheer him on to go you don't want
thank God because people think that
we're like [ __ ] mooks is commerce I
hate you from flop in 90 different
directions you could just axe [ __ ] we
could do it all and when we get 30 years
under our belt we become weapons like
Jimmy Smits like any of these people
that have been doing it for 30-plus
[ __ ] years eventually you're gonna
get [ __ ] good at it you know so you
know I still didn't see the Tarantino
movie I saw the Joker Tarantino movies
amazing I saw I won't stay down a
disrespect for Bruce Lee
I saw the joke I just don't even want to
go there with no one I'm not going if he
didn't [ __ ] live through it I don't
want to hear his [ __ ] take on it it's
it's not it doesn't make sense it
disrespected Shannon so it means that
disrespected me you in you disrespected
my [ __ ] power
now you know I don't even know Shannon
Lee yeah the fella bunch of these people
got fired up I watched the Joker I liked
it though the Joker was intense I liked
the joke that was intense
I saw uncle James during the break I
went to Christmas night my [ __ ] girls
went to sleep so I was little with the
little Emily ate three edibles and my
heart was beating with that [ __ ]
because that movies Joey Diaz 83 to 84
whatever you want to do we're going to
do what do you want to do with you Joe
Rogan listen I got I got someone coming
next week let me get 20 G's till next
week there ain't no next week Jamie
don't say nothing orokin I need tend to
[ __ ] and put this number in and it just
goes thinking your life from there you
borrow from Peter to pay Paul and then
you're telling hey Zeus to suck your
dick it's not stop people like don't get
high and go see it
[ __ ] you I'm going deep don't see it I'd
prepare like a table at huh who's in it
just I'm saying with a bunch of [ __ ]
whatever's it's just a movie of all the
basketball player that you don't know
what a good Kevin Garnett okay and it's
it's nonstop so it's mostly Sandler and
it's bumping into Oh what happened to my
dirty Wow I'll catch you next week I
gotta go yeah you [ __ ] you know
it's [ __ ] constant it's you know that
life and then it traumatic is an Academy
Award winner I don't [ __ ] know you
know I took it home I ward for a couple
days it's okay there's anything in the
[ __ ] Academy award-winner anymore I
watched the Irishman you gonna see it
yet either so you're skiing for three
hours what are you doing these flights
you look at here then which way for him
to go to sleep then you go to sleep you
[ __ ] you get that's when I watch these
three hour movies I can't watch them at
home I got a seven-year-old on flights a
wife lights I try to write sometimes
I've come up with some of my best bits
while writing no no that's after the
movie but you yeah it's a five-hour 51
minute flight that's true so I usually
do a little you know I will listen to
music I get tuned up I eat whatever they
give
me I [ __ ] put the movie on and I got
the notebook right on the iPad so
someone comes to me you tighten it up
and then you got the whole night that
night in your hotel room but no I like
the Irishman do you write on your iPad
yeah somebody got a screener do you have
one of those detachable keyboards I have
the keyboard with the screen and I just
typed like I'm usually so that's why I
put the final product now so now it's I
have a notebook still but I [ __ ] around
but different stupid ideas
and then once the joke works I put on
the iPad now and I could add tags to it
Oh sound like I used to before so now I
but you're just typing on the iPad
screen just like a phone right you know
you don't have a keyboard that you know
has a keyboard oh you have a yes okay it
saved my life the best happen when you
know that it's basically like a little
laptop listen to me no Twitter no
Facebook no nothing oh I got YouTube
Netflix Hulu and that writing app mmm
that's it that's my rest of the hotel
room that's good for your Friday night
nobody [ __ ] you if you Facebook me out
Friday night and I'm on the road you
suck my dick just Twitter the same thing
I don't want to look at it on the road
that's the distraction so on the road I
don't want to do podcasts I don't want
to do nothing
yeah I want to lift a little bit maybe
go a little [ __ ] local kickboxing
school and do a workout but I want to
focus on that writing that six hours
worth ain't no [ __ ] Hemingway just to
make little adjustments from the night
before
yeah that's it well you know you got
this time when you're on the road and
you can use it in a way that's gonna
help you it can be it could be
beneficial or you could just use it just
one or two things right you got to
figure out like what's optimal for you
when you're on the road for me I always
have better sets when I work out you
have to work out always you have to work
I don't like that weird fog that I feel
when I fly into somewhere and then I
just like get ready for the show my
chest [ __ ] there's something about
like it's hard to get everything going
but if you just get on an elliptical
machine for 20 minutes it points listen
to some good music and just say there's
no
option you have to do this just [ __ ]
do this once 10 minutes gets going then
you're sweating you're having a good
time then you're fine for 40 minutes or
more we've been friends the 23 years
you've been taking me on the road for 20
of those years we could not do what we
were doing 20 years on the road today
not because I'm not calling you out
because you have a children your wife
you have a thousand other
responsibilities so Tuesday's you can
tell you those chosen him around
yeah it's Sunday's out to Sunday's octo
so it's also it's like you you you can
get a lot out of that when you're in
those early stages like we were when we
were learning how to do the road just a
lot you get out of those Wednesday
through Sunday weekends weeks you know
why because my fine you want to stab
yourself in the throw from saying the
same joke yeah you wake up Saturday
morning and you run like a [ __ ]
yeah
because Saturday you got three shows
when we went through this free show
pattern you said to me when I don't
Midnight's numb what's not worth it
yeah it's the law of diminishing returns
you didn't know a joke you [ __ ] said
by midnight yeah
even if you stayed sober you didn't
smoke then Wilma Sobers jams you still
are like tonight you [ __ ] say this
bit so that's just a burner that's the
law of diminishing returns
Sunday's people are tired they don't
they don't have the same reaction on
Sunday you and I were never tired then
but there was no children involved there
was no serious girlfriends involved
there was not a lot of it
no podcast wasn't involved there was a
lot of different things then now my
schedule has to be this you don't meet a
home I could [ __ ] take the Friday
flight that way I can take the Friday
six-hour flight at 6 a.m. Landon County
at 2:00 and be a town hall ready to go
at 8:00 but do I really want to do that
do I need to do that no thought that
this six a.m. on Thursday
get to New York to take a little nap at
4:00 go downstairs do the elliptical get
to five pounds shadow box for ten
minutes because I don't believe in
shadow boxes hmm breaks a tremendous one
yeah Barbra jams you go upstairs also
moving you bang one out in the shower
well get yourself up and you hang you go
for a nice stage and you get to see the
town and then I do what I learned from
my brother Joe Rogan you
even [ __ ] huge tip so when they offer
employee like the word gets out the Joe
Rogan in town Friday morning you wake up
the show sold that I don't have to go to
Arabia you knows that that's this plan
yeah and then you get up Friday a local
kickboxing school I'm always that just
yeah and they're looking at you like mr.
Rogan a you shouldn't yeah I'm doing the
class I'm gonna meet a few people you
get more than that than anything they
talk to it they bust your balls a little
bit but then you get an uber set to pick
you up and you go back to the old town
you actually got out you were social
before the show mm-hmm - the hotel room
and sitting there for six hours and
egged your rightful one you throw an
episode of The Sopranos I hunt for one
you're throwing up pasilla to something
else then you go back to writing maybe
you take a nap take a nice 20 minutes
shower and do a seven o'clock show in
case you sell out you do the second show
but if not you're back in your room you
throw on a movie you haven't seen even
edible you're up at 5:00 you're at the
airport insects you're back in LAX at
night I want to see this documentary it
sounds perfect that's that's that what
works for me now for me to be most
effective you know I could be a gov on
and go out there on Wednesdays but by
Saturday I'm not gonna be a good comic
yeah I think we still be a good comic
putting the reps and put it in the raps
in town it's just about reps you know as
many reps as you can get the thing about
the road when you're doing those
Wednesday through Sundays is that you're
getting long reps you getting like our
sets every show which is great - I'm not
I'm not I think for me as where we're at
now I want to give him honor 50% of his
show last night I went to the comedy
store I got to dick-sucking 's right out
of the way I mean I sucked the bag a
dick in the main room and then I took
that same as in the original room
insecticide dicks but I wanted to try
new material see I was failing in the
past I was going all these other clubs
and going I mean I
let me not try shut the comm you still
listen you bring everything to the
chapel at the Comedy Store and let the
pieces fall where there may it's 15 to
get it you do know that now ya see 22
comics and they're gonna see 22 comics
that headline all over the world
so suck my dick I'm gonna go thank you
50% but I'm looking up there trying new
[ __ ] last night I was talking about that
we've always met at one time or another
me to somebody that's how you learn not
to be a meet or is by me doing somebody
one time and then you go that wasn't
right and then I'll never meet two again
for me I was weird adjectives all I
started out with it I opened up with it
to really put myself in the [ __ ] hole
of that is that there was a class an
adverb what is that
me too and is it a verb if you meet you
somebody has to be an adverb yeah second
yeah the only way you learned out of me
the only way you learn how to not beat
me to meet or is by me doing you
shoplift a candy when you were a kid
right yeah and your mother told you
smack nice because that's not right same
time with me doing this la is a [ __ ]
me too was invented here they [ __ ]
Marilyn's Martin Monroe to death they
did that a vaginal thing looks like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] Embassy in Tehran
whatever they bombed what was that
famous Fatty Arbuckle case where there
was a disgusting people is you know
between the Bikram documentary did you
see that one I didn't see that filthy
[ __ ] animal getting women to suck
that [ __ ] 90 degree weather six yoga
session dick that's just cruelty to
animals you could put you in jail for
just sucking that desk you know the
Harvey all that [ __ ] happens here but as
us as men we've all made some money when
you were a kid my mistake for me I was
in love with this lady named fate she
was 37 at big juicy tits she'd wear hot
pants I was about 14 I had never even
seen a vagina no titties nothing and we
used to play basketball and our two dogs
were blind
she had French poodles
and she had flip-flops and she crossed
the street and she was so hot she was 38
and she had an her husband that was like
60 he would just barely be alive like
that dude from Texas that was [ __ ] a
Howard Marshall
and he would watch her cuz he knew he
was savage through things like that she
had two daughters and the daughters were
badass and but one of my goombas dated
one of the daughters I never told him I
was alive each time I play basketball
failure would come on the game would you
stop and she turned for us and the Sun
would shine through a halt
remember all the time in the seventies
and she had really yummy titties with
the nipple stick another drove me crazy
I was 13 14 I love who that I'd see her
in the window with pants on she looked
delicious and finally summer of [ __ ]
79 I'm getting all [ __ ] up with some
friends of mine I've been drinking
[ __ ] nips we started some angel dust
and we're listening to Led Zeppelin - if
you're gonna [ __ ] his body
Led Zeppelin - is the album to give you
it starts off with a whole lot of love
that just gets your hips moving and then
it goes into the lemon song and he's
talking about squeeze me baby - the
juice runs down my leg
I'm like that's it the juice is running
down my leg my mother was a flower
chicks yet flowers everywhere I put on
like a shirt I swear to god it had to be
about that because she would walk the
dog at night but the husband called you
15 the dog would sleep that the husband
would pass out by 8:00 so she would take
the dogs out for the 10 o'clock the last
she would pull him down and you know
they were kind of blind French poodles
and she was still wearing a [ __ ]
tighty whities you know the defense
Dixie deuce
is in the 70s before days even it was
invented she already had the Daisy on
with the shirt and I remember being on
that angel dust hiding in the weeds
exception like [ __ ] and with the flowers
that flowers for I was gonna bring her
flowers but my plan was to attack it
like his jumper in the thing throw it
down and get with the flowers is how
crazy she was gonna attack her
like I couldn't take it normal like I
wanted to marry her like that's how
[ __ ] about anywhere not an angel dust
and I was on edge of this it was what I
would tease see crystal call it what you
want it's animal tranquilizer
no matter how you look at it and I
remember that I ran up on her and she
turned and she goes Coco what's going on
I go and I just stopped when I go fight
I'm in love with you I said what are you
talking about I'm I fell in love with
you for two years I want to run off with
you [ __ ] my mother I'm like I just let's
get a job let's let's leave Wow
and she's looking at me like wait a lot
like I was [ __ ] first of all she's
gonna be like this kid is [ __ ]
snapped and she have you been drinking
and like I still love you take the
flowers and she was I'll tell you what
if I divorce my husband I'm considerate
and I was like okay I can live with that
can I give you a kiss I like kissed her
on the cheek I like to feel the heat
going up my head and finally as I went
to turn away I looked at her like she
had the juiciest legs in the world I
know can I touch your thigh and she goes
go ahead Jerome and that's like her
kneecap and my dick just exploded that
sperm I ran away like Steven Seagal
honestly Steve mister got run he runs
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] put that little
lip be Steven Seagal run there's a
couple for you ever see him run and he
runs very straight and was very tall
what's the first one he did that's
really good love the law look at him
look at how he rise he runs like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] look at him look at him
can you imagine he's just built odd he's
just really tall he does run a little
loose with the hands which is kind of
confusing which one was this one this is
that's a sector that's above the law
it's cut no it's got no oh it's all it's
a bunch of different movies now because
now he's got more hair right because
people goof on them because of the way
he runs yeah he was married to Kelly
LeBrock dog at one time dude one time he
was the man how many times I jerk off to
Kelly LeBrock and woman in red one of
Gene Wilder calls to her he this is what
it is his steps are too short and his
wrists flip around because he's used to
do in Aikido right
you still like Jojo don't put that going
please don't protect them no don't throw
ice you know in there those Japanese
people work 3,000 years to put Aikido on
the map and now you're gonna set the
back that poor aikido school and Burbank
has moved eight times they keep losing
students it down to two students wearing
a smock and a [ __ ] sword who's gonna
go for Aikido as someone who doesn't
really want to fight and you want to you
want to be able to passively get someone
away from you which is not realistic but
the sword part the sword part could come
up if [ __ ] hits the fan if we go back
and you know if we get knocked into the
Stone Age nuclear war with Russia we
gonna see a beat now and he's joined
again no dodged sticks yeah they moved
their bird back and I've thought about
when I was a kid I went to Aikido for
about two weeks it's probably fun the
guy's name was Richard ball he was I
supposed to be a big time and gottenberg
New Jersey mm-hmm and he taught that
deflection stuff but Steven Seagal and
above the Lord took it to a different
level that out that a harm that throat
slam oh yeah he's got the deflection
throat slam that's [ __ ] beautiful I
had a meeting with a guy in a in a movie
there's this like my agent sent me in to
meet with this guy they were looking for
someone to do like a Steven Seagal type
movie they were looking to they were
gonna try to create an action star and
we actually had like a argument about
this movie that move right there but the
less poisonous throat I got carried away
of the law and the one we [ __ ] up the
Jamaicans oh yeah which one was that
without swords then sword fighting and
hard to kill wasn't that that's the one
that pissed me off as well oh you're in
a coma for four years into these two
days later you throw in a sidekick yeah
and he's putting like Jesus Christ
Jesus Christ yeah I loved it I'm on time
I love to do I loved in to I like the
thing about him man is I think in that
first movie it was one of the more
unique martial arts movies like above
the law like it's almost a shame that he
made a bunch of movies that weren't as
good because if you go back to above the
law in terms of like martial arts
history and above the law is a
legitimate historical movie in terms of
martial arts movies because it was the
first movie where you got to see a real
Aikido practitioner with a hybridized
system of martial arts like he was doing
our Kido but he was also throwing a lot
of punches and knife hand strikes and a
lot of strikes it was a showed the
bodega feed and above the law just split
play this out that's the bet all y'alls
this guy look at all the [ __ ]
I mean I've made fun of him as much as
anybody but listen his Aikido skills
were very legit
he was very legit whether or not that
stuff's real or not that's a subject for
debate whether or not it's really
effective when you look at other things
like wrestling and jiu-jitsu is it the
most effective way to grow or judo is
the most effective way no it's not but
no one knew that back then and he at the
time in the 1980s and 90s was a
world-class martial artist he just had a
style that ultimately didn't really
prove to be the best style but so did I
I was doing this is this is hard to kill
a lot of people were doing kung fu a lot
of people were doing things that they
thought were legit but they really wants
the UFC came around we found out oh this
is not the best way to do it
this is 87 that's a kid in this scene
that was just in a movie with Clint
Eastwood Emile he's been doing movies
for [ __ ] 30 years I can't right now
that dude with the tattoos how many
[ __ ] movies is he's been a bad guy in
right there the second guy that guys in
every [ __ ] bad guy everyone great
quiz he what's his name he used to live
in Vegas I heard he had some a
restaurant and they not even sure
I love a good shitty drama a good shitty
cop drama like I love I love like going
back and watching some 1990s cop dramas
they're fun
Kojak Oh pop at the end
how about beretta but rather how about
that [ __ ] you know which one was good
bro
that they gotta bring back but wise guy
what was wise guy a good-looking dude
with the [ __ ] he was undercover with
the Mafia but he really was a cop from
the CIA like a Donnie Brasco type
situationally good-looking dude really a
good-looking this is it right here he
[ __ ] people up no no this is a movie
wiseguy was a TV show is robust isn't it
Robert wall Robert good-looking dude he
came out with Paul Newman and uh Fort
Apache the Bronx oh why is God the TV
series what am I looking at here Jamie
just fell back remember that guy yeah
you remember that do Rock who's that
dude does it say see go to just a
regular search of it instead of watching
the video of it that's right there are
so many of the number wings wings forget
and Jan Michael Vincent yes
was he sure that's no no no wings was
the TV show on NBC right yeah Jan
Michael Vincent wasn't in wings
wait Jan Michael Vincent wasn't some
show about [ __ ] and war Ken wall Kenton
Jan Michael Vincent was in some movie
about a TV show about pilots in the air
that hunted you down on CBS that's when
he went [ __ ] that's when he went crazy
that's what he wanted crazy well he went
crazy like straight from the the
mechanic like he went I think it was
famed that probably did that guy in
write famous alcoholism yeah but a lot
of that is probably the bear wolf and
telecare werewolf yeah
seasons that guy in the mechanic if you
go back to the the original Charles
Bronson version the mechanics he was
slated to be the next big superstar
right he was he did a movie for Disney
with the Kurt Russell called the world's
greatest athlete and right Dave [ __ ]
things up he was he was a Disney guy
first you don't know the world's
greatest happily uh he went to pick up
the weights in his arm stretched him and
[ __ ] that was his first movie it was
a Disney movie and then he went on to
become Jam Mike when the mechanic look
yeah look at him dogs who's handsome dog
he was the first Brad Pitt he was look
how gripped he is - he was the runner up
it look at this science fiction where
he's out sprinting black guys there's a
science fiction movie this is a science
fiction this is why he was the greatest
the world's greatest that with beautiful
hair this white guy is out sprinting
everyone else looks like they're
straight out of Jamaica right out of
Jamaica track to you this is a
ridiculous film look how much further he
is ahead of than those guys who you know
would beat him in a real race he would
the black people cheering for me even
the brothers at Rikers he did look
[ __ ] fantastic back then though like
look what kind of shape that guy was in
look at the guy from good times Howard
this is a great movie this is one of his
first movies that blew him up Danny got
the mechanic and [ __ ] that's how they
kill him people today with the rock good
times dr. T Beach a member that [ __ ]
saw an audition about 15 years ago the
wander the neighbor oh that's an she
still look good she's the neighbor lady
yes Guinea door pull up the cast of the
good times dude this this show
JJ Walker still to this day is known for
one saying dynomite if he won't say
unless you'd give me three grand
then I'm gonna send them back I don't
know Chloe's had given him 1500 a week
and he's like who you want me to say
dynamo yeah but wait give me that like
that the names of everybody just go to
Hall yeah look at that [ __ ] show 1974
first episode this was a show like every
that was interesting right because there
was a Jackson it was a quite a few even
though there wasn't that many television
shows there was quite a few big-name
black shows Sanford and Son good times
The Jeffersons like during that era even
though there weren't that many TV shows
there was quite a sizable show Oh shadow
tremendous yeah I forgot about that show
tremendous yeah dude
to this day Sanford and Son is one of
the best sitcoms of all time there's
some [ __ ] episodes of Sanford and Son
that I'll listen to or watch rather to
this day and I'll still laugh at Faso
[ __ ] raw and I wish Network television
would look at that and go it's time for
us to take the sticks out of our ass
again they can't they're stuck well
somebody has to do it first it's just
gonna be their own demise no you know
what comedians you're a comedian i'ma
come and I try real hard
this was our early education this class
and a better education than watching and
here we're watching remember watching
Paul Mooney write these lines mm-hmm
Paul Mooney was one of the writers on
this so we had Richard Pryor on one hand
but then you had this sick [ __ ]
he hated Puerto Ricans I don't want no
border regions my house
he hated the other name the other
neighbor Kyle America this is Friday
nights and then it was followed by Chico
and the man yes
you know Freddie Prinze CBS had their
answer a [ __ ] of Archie Bunker which
will never happen again every year they
try to do under different aren't you
bunker they're never gonna do it cuz
it's not coming from the heart yeah they
can't sell it like he did that he does a
sane when when he hit one Sammy Davis
jr. has to kiss him like there's a scene
of [ __ ] when Sammy Davis close the
actor's name again Carroll Carroll
O'Connor telecom Michalka he grabbed Cal
O'Connor and kissed him in the [ __ ]
lips that you know melida forget right
here all this [ __ ] you know what's crazy
Carol Connor was like a great actor an
actor for his whole life
but he's known for sure more than
anything for being Archie Bunker right
here look at his face yeah like it was
supposed to be funny that Archie Bunker
was racist I'm by the way just for the
record there would be always thought he
was a black Jew you better throw Cuban
in there - his mother was Cuban Sammy
Davis jr. yeah his mother was Cuban I'm
afro-cuban now look at everyone laughing
at him because Sammy Davis jr. kissed
him he freaked out look at everyone
laughing at him you kid like gay jokes
black jokes white jokes Puerto Rican
jokes they they talk [ __ ] about
everybody on that show you go back in TV
male ten years and you never see the
difference you go back and film and
there's some films that write off this
start there are offensive oh yeah they
'z world a very offensive I just saw
something that was on like regular TV of
me and my wife and I would this wouldn't
fly today it was just something that was
on like at nine o'clock
wouldn't fly but what about Ace Ventura
pet detective
it was all about a guy who was trans a
guy who was pretend it was
cross-dressing at the very least like
pretending to be a girl but it turns out
to be a guy the whole time and
everyone's disgusted because they kissed
him thinking it was a girl so everyone's
throwing up and like you would never be
able to do that today it would be
transphobic people would freak out
do you remember that no there's that
pretty lady who was in a bunch of movies
back then but then just like went off
the rails
Shawn young remember her she was in
Blade Runner she was the beautiful young
robot in Blade Runner she was in a bunch
of movies man but then she just went off
the rails
she she's one of those Gen Michael
Vincent type characters for a bit I
think well just a pressure of it all was
just too much so this is the scene at
the end of it does that Courtney Cox
with the gun yeah and there's Sean Young
that's that lady and so we find out in
this scene that he's really or she's
really a guy or I don't get it or she's
how do you say it today you can say it's
a guy pretending to be a girl but you
don't say that anymore now now you say
what she's trans so but we're supposed
to believe that she's got a giant hog
under there where's the scene oh yeah
he's got a lead up to he's explained
yeah I think to them so he tells them
all that that's a guy so this is like
some bad guy they've been looking he's
the famous kicker from Miami Dolphin
that's right oh that's right Wow
that's right that's right and he's angry
because he [ __ ] up but you know all
these cops know about this one game yeah
boom there's the part so she's supposed
to have a tucked in right there rights
or something and they all flip around
tone lokes in there too there's Captain
Winky no he's good he's gonna turn her
around so everybody can see that she's
got a hog turn around
what's it yeah cuz it's the big reveal
there it is look at them all throw up
everyone's throw it up like tone locusts
clean his tongue up your dog's gone up
strung up now he saw a woman with a dick
so let me ask you a question a couple of
weeks ago Disney Plus for me
mmm two days later people drawing fits
what do you want them to do to go back
and take all this [ __ ] of is all movies
well that's a good question what do you
do you ever go to Disneyland you have
that one ride what is it a Splash
Mountain yes that Splash Mountain ride
is based on a movie that you can't even
watch anymore Liz it was a really racist
movie Walt Disney was racist was he not
I don't know I don't know this Splash
Mountain was places this is it's called
the song of the south that was the movie
and it from what year is that Jamie 6
1946 probably people were different
animals back to her we're not even the
same species was about the lady who sang
the national anthem at the Yankees
somebody found out that 30 years before
that you didn't know about that
no you gotta look this up she sang songs
that were like totally racist like
spooky get out of town like [ __ ] like
this please look it up right nationally
right now so two ball fields took her
version of the national anthem now you
had to read this [ __ ] she was handsome
ence god bless america
out at Yankee Stadium over racist song
listen to the song she said whose kids
I'm [ __ ] fat chick from 19 2013 19 31
song yeah
that's why [ __ ] were born wait a
minute she sang this in 1931 yeah how
old is this [ __ ] is he still alive it's
like the recording of God Bless America
from back then that they used to just
play during right she sang that but when
did she when she was record in 1937 the
way
did she sing the national anthem no no
it's the god Bless America is what
they're talking about here okay but when
did she sing god bless america
1929 1930 something I don't know back
then but she also song sang a song
called that's why [ __ ] a boy I was
confused I was thinking you were saying
that she sang it at listen to the lyrics
someone she pick cotton
someone had to pick the corn someone had
this be a slave if somebody had this
thing that's why [ __ ] were born oh
that you know I mean all these things
the song which has been called a
satirical take on racism was a big hit
for Smith and also was recorded by a
Paul Robeson hmm hmm so she wrote and
sang god Bless America so the version
that you would hear like God she sang it
so that recorded it so the version that
you would hear would be back then right
so yeah see that's a that's why she gets
weird you know there's been a lot of
great people over the years that have
had some horrible ideas oh so you have
to wonder like like if we just cut out
the guy I mean how many people different
people who have invented incredible
things that we use all the time we're
also really shitty human beings like you
know about that Fritz hopper guy the guy
that he created this ability to this
method to extract nitrogen from the
atmosphere and then use it as fertilizer
because the air apparently you think of
the air is oxygen it's not most of what
you're breathing in most of what our air
is is 80s I think it's like 80 something
percent nitrogen and so this guy figured
out a way how to extract nitrogen from
the air and because that population
boomed because we had more food because
they could they could lay down more more
fertilizer so he did something good yeah
but he also invented nerve gas he was
the first guy to propose and implement a
poison gas strategy against against
Europe when they were when the UK and
when the whatever the the whole group
and what was was how World War one or
two where they did that I want to say
it's too right
is it to whatever war it was in they
were the first people to get so this guy
who had created the harbor method for
extracting nitrogen at the same time was
wanted for war crimes because he figured
out how to gasps gasps the the enemy and
he was working for the Nazis and he was
a Jew the whole thing is crazy it gets
even crazier they eventually started
imprisoning Jews and kicked them out of
the country and he's still there and so
he eventually winds up leaving his tail
is [ __ ] crazy but that guy also
invented the same gas they used to gas
the the gas the Jews and concentration
camps he invented it but he invented it
with a smell to it
so you could detect it and they were
gonna use it as like I think it was a
pesticide or something like that
you talking about a monster yeah I
thought I think it's a chemist he's John
Lennon he he wrote Benny and the Jets
please Maggie Yoko I'm saying no misdeal
a monster but he's one of the like that
he's seen fifty percent of the nitrogen
in our bodies today are from the Harbor
method fifty percent so he invented
something that literally changed the way
people couldn't eat I mean they probably
saved billions of lives I mean I don't
know I mean I'm just guessing but I
would imagine one of the biggest
problems that people had back then was
when you couldn't grow things places
when you didn't have enough food I mean
it was a real touch-and-go situation
before refrigeration and then before you
know large-scale trucking and
agriculture everywhere like we have
today and how much of the nitrogen that
we use came because this guy figured out
otherwise they would just use like dead
fish and things like that they'd have
like compost that's what fertilizer was
bones would grind up bones but he's also
a monster also you know they figured
through his work how to kill people with
gas they just gassed entire troops
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] man when no one had
never done that before I mean you got to
think back then people would I mean
think about this the the the war the
independence war right the war for
independence against England when they
would wear the British where those crazy
outfits with the white right across
their chest they were perfect targets
they'd be walking to the forest and
these Hillbillies just pick them out
because they were walking like they're
in some sort of old-timey war like they
used to do wars like they had rules for
war
now there's rules for engagement and
then when a general would lose he would
hand his sword over to the other men
sometimes they wouldn't even take it
because they were trying to be polite
and they would have these rules like
gentlemen rules for killing people and
then this guy came out with a method hey
how about this have we were just gassy
some other [ __ ] just drop gas on them
kill everybody just you let them choke
to death in their own blood literally
your body just vomiting blood it's
coming out of your eyeballs everyone
around you is dying from the same thing
you just hemorrhaging just dying because
some genius scientist who also created a
method to extract nitrogen out of the
air that fed millions of hungry people
also figured out a way to do this
awesome [ __ ] up it's [ __ ] up
you just breathe me out yeah well
sometimes great people have done
horrible horrible things but that guy
invented something that we all use it's
a it's a tricky thing being a person you
know people are slippery
there's a lot of good and bad about us
it depends how you use it yes it depends
how you use it well that's why being a
comic is like one of the most fulfilling
things of all time because people get
something out of it like if they go to
see you like the reason why you're
willing to eat dick it's because you
want to develop these bits and have them
crush get them to that point or when
people come to see and they pay money to
see you boom you lay them on them and
like that feeling that you can do that
you can give to something when you see
someone just laughing so hard there's
one of the greatest feelings a person
can ever experience and not a lot of
people get to experience and you imagine
how important laughs there is in your
life so have for a certain point like
it's urine it's like you know you need
sleep yeah you need food
and if you really have a laughter but
you also have to learn how to laugh at
yourself yes
and once you conquer that your life
changes completely
yeah that's 50% you know you know the
number one killer is stress that's
number one you think I could kill you
yeah is you being stressed out but humor
I mean I love getting high at night
doing edibles and finding stupid videos
this is watching that whole stand-up
real yeah I'm just laughing my [ __ ]
ass off I love it I love it I'm enjoying
it more every day when you have kids you
really laugh at this [ __ ] they talk
about you know did I laugh at kids
movies I watched Dora the Explorer the
the live-action one one the new one we
remember it's hilarious this summer was
legit laughs in that movie I got bad
movie people the last couple of years
I've gone to see maybe seven or eight
mainstream films by probably seeing 20
kid films yeah and I leave those films
blown away so you know what's [ __ ]
great Jumanji I had a new one it's as
good if not better than the first one
the first one was [ __ ] great those
damn great well at least you leave there
feeling something you know some of these
movies I go watch I'm like what the [ __ ]
was fast
Jumanji hits a perfect balance between
it's like it's a family movie but you
don't treat you like you're a [ __ ]
it's fun and it's it's you know they're
trapped in a video game so it doesn't
have to make sense it can be crazy and
so it is crazy but it's a [ __ ] great
movie it's a great movie both of them
are great they're fun you leave you feel
good you laugh your ass off good and
they ride the edge perfectly of it being
enjoyable for old people but hilarious
for kids kids think Jumanji hilarious so
you could sit there why you know I took
my nine-year-old the other day we
watched it for the second time just me
and her laughing ah that was so funny
the rock is great Kevin Hartz great that
chick who plays I don't want a spoiler
alert and then she plays more than one
for some strange reason I can't I don't
spoil it but she's [ __ ] fantastic
that uh the Asian lady that was in crazy
rich Asians what is her name
Ayane FINA yeah how crazy is that name
she make that name up she must have was
a rapper too she's a rapper yes she was
also no yeah really yeah no well that
make sense yeah I can't say without
giving it away why she's so good but
goddamn she's hilarious yeah well I like
the most that has really given me a
great bond with my daughter that some of
these Pixar movies use music from our
era oh you don't know how many times
she's I'm gonna car driving I'm
listening to classic rock and she's in
the back saying it and I'm like my dick
just got hard
she knows my music you marry me she
knows yeah music yeah and it's because
of those I don't know what Pixar movie
are exactly but they use music from our
era and she'll go Daddy I know that song
let me see the video well they do that
with some movies like Marvel did it the
best with guardians of the galaxy Chris
Pratt's character is into cool old songs
like if you ride the ride at Disneyland
they have a guardians of the galaxy ride
and in it there's all these cool songs
like Jackson 5 or slow ride like crazy
cool old school songs that play while
he's going through his adventure so part
of guardians of the galaxy
he's got headphones on what is that song
he's listening to yeah he's got this one
song he's got a old-school cassette
walkman and he's got the headphones on a
[ __ ] and he's kicking the [ __ ] out of
aliens while he's listening to this
badass on but it's like those old
classics there's something about songs
that are from a different time that it's
it's not just that it's a great song but
it's also that its history like it's
both things you know using my total
business to I want to kill myself hooked
on a feeling that's it blue suede all
that
music drives me [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] my
life that one Jam you know what's the
one that came with a Miley Cyrus's
father oh yeah yeah old town road knows
how killed your [ __ ] house oh my god
kids wouldn't stop saying they wouldn't
stop my daughter was saying it well I
think that's the most popular single of
all time of all time that's amazing
parking now yeah I remember one thing
when I first stepped foot on the stage
about a year later Billy Ray Cyrus blue
oh yeah I still remember doing open mic
that followed a breakdance what was it
called line dancing class yeah in
Colorado Nevada Colorado on Sunday night
don't tell my heart yeah a keeper people
went nuts yeah to see him is what I'm
talking about that I love when people
hope Billy Ray Cyrus he's dead really
no he just showed up with a kid and blew
up the [ __ ] world 35 30 years later
I'll tell you what man his daughter is
very talented his daughter has very
talented yeah no she hasn't even got
started you don't even worry about it
listen it's Jolene you listen to her her
cover Jolene like holy [ __ ] man bro she
sang some she sang when we leave here
put on [ __ ] him she's a tribute to Chris
Cornell mmm what's she saying and you're
gonna die yeah just say goodbyes say
hello to heaven I get goose chase she
she hasn't even let her go show up man
she's gonna get married if you time have
fun she's got enough dough the last
three lifetimes right yeah so let her go
do the thing but the true qualities I
come back hmm and she's gonna hold Advil
the music industry yeah because she's
yeah say about him well I think it's yes
it will have Temple of the dog
say hello to heaven yeah I want to hear
this later bookmark that for me Jamie
god I wish we could play music yeah she
[ __ ] there's any great I just played
music during the podcast yeah we gotta
get some you have no idea how talented
she she's phenomenal I love her last
album song Malibu
you heard yeah it's a great [ __ ] song
he's just taking time off but she's a
real artist first she got on the I'm not
gonna smoke dope like Pete Thames and
that [ __ ] last Pete Davidson the pussy's
too good I gotta be gettin ya know they
go on that cake they're not gonna smoke
no more you know you gotta do something
I love the reef I love it in the morning
I get to I got some Strawberry Cough the
other day oh my god have you seen the
speed weed a box of doom you gotta open
that thing up it lights up like like the
suitcase in Pulp Fiction and these
little tobacco things yeah blunts I love
you not a blind guy I'm not a boy I am a
black guy now
I love his blood yeah well you know who
turned me into a blunt guy is Charlie
Murphy Charlie Murphy the first time I
ever got high with him he rolled a blunt
and he would do it old school he would
buy packages swisher Sweets he'd cut
those [ __ ] open you know a lot of
guys break him up with their finger I
don't remember if he broke it open with
his finger but Charlie knew how to roll
a blunt like he would roll a blunt you
know who else rolls a blunt real good
Luis Gomez Luis Gomez rolls a legit
blunt breaks down the tobacco takes the
[ __ ] leaf out flattens the leave
rolls the weed inside of it perfect
blunt like skills like I'm admire dudes
who can fix things and I admire dudes
who could roll a tight joint you know
like a dude who knows how to fix an
engine like oh you carburetor is this
and that we're just gonna run the line
we'll clear it out and then we'll add
new spark plugs and like a bow I can't
do that I gotta hire a guy to do that I
can't turn the wrench I'm not good at it
I never learned I admire it
I get I could I could [ __ ] roll a
nasty joint I had more that I can't do
the blunted special thing you got to
learn how to break down the tobacco and
I cheat sometimes and by the bluff rap
but it's just not the same you know last
week I called you after I did bird sting
and he had a Cuban doing doing cigars
and Burt said till dementia
question what if I gave me an ounce of
dough can you roll it up and he rolled
it up into a cigar oh my god and they
will [ __ ] tremendous I mean [ __ ]
tremendous Tommy Chong gave me this yeah
it's too big listen it's all cute it
starts off cute like you burn me you
know you burn a ninja bit of two
laughter I don't want to light it though
I'll miss it I like keeping it right
here on my desk as a kid when I was
little big bamboo my stepdad they've had
a big bamboo but I listened to it when I
was like I mean I couldn't have been
more than nine I was nine years old and
I was listen to that I'm the have system
aerial phenomena I don't remember I
remember it I think big bamboo was the
one whether like Dave's not here man
I think that was that one just to know
those guys [ __ ] genius is that Tommy
Chong is a goddamn genius and so Cheech
that they still put they put a rolling
paper in the thing and yeah
the album was wrong page yes it's system
elephant yes Ralph and Herbie let's make
a dope deal that's right let's make a
dope deal if you want me to tell you
something this is why I got into
podcasting this was my biggest appeal
about podcasting that guys like you and
I grew up listening to prior yeah John
yep Carlin and I'm like I listen my my
albums of choice as a kid were there
were three by Richard Pryor this one and
I like the Lenny Bruce live from
Carnegie Hall for some reason hmm that's
my album collection of stand-up comedy I
love a Bicentennial negative [ __ ]
crazy as if something was it something I
said
that's Richard Pryor's best work those
are great creates rich all rises much
more great great alamos but just raw and
it makes you listen you know this year
was the first time since 1987 that
albums outsold DVDs they're making a big
comeback
really we made a big [ __ ] mistake 30
is
we all drank the [ __ ] kool-aid and
there wasn't worth it there was some
jerk-off people you know again what Iman
we were we were doing great with the
album the music industry was doing great
with a thing called the arm why because
you want to buy kiss on Saturday this
[ __ ] guy wants to buy Led Zeppelin
and I want to buy REO Speedwagon you all
got paper outs on Saturday we got to
walk down to the [ __ ] record store
look around he changed his mind he went
with Jethro Tull then we went back to
Yost cuz your mom worked on Saturdays
and we got two joints and we rolled them
up in the album and it was a process you
put the Almonte and you rolled and you
read the lyrics and you read the things
that they put in it then they took that
away from you and they gave you the
first dudes with the dudes what to the
reel-to-reel oh yeah I didn't know
anybody personally yeah nobody was
buying you know you got to be on a show
up with a movie thing to listen to
[ __ ] Julie and you got a Spruill it in
the hotel so that one out [ __ ] quick
then they would they switch to something
else in track then we said oh no the
8-track was already gone pretty much
yeah that's my track started to move out
cassette was big cassettes were big
everybody dies what's that many discs
many discs many this Wow and then I
remember the CD but then I still
remember buying like movies like going
on me but buying a movie opening up the
thing and it just be like an advertiser
and a [ __ ] CD oh and that's when I
stopped I go this is what I'm getting
for my money now so when I buy a [ __ ]
CD from a record label I open it up and
it's a CD would have didn't even don't
even put time into the cover anymore
when you buy Pink Floyd's wish you were
here out Jesus Christ
they must have put a year just into the
cover hmm the guy shaking the guy's hand
and Warner Brothers the other guys like
on fire yeah they put time in so I think
that and everybody kept saying sound
well the sound CD didn't listen just to
put that [ __ ] needle on
again I wonder how many [ __ ]
turntables are sold in America last year
for the album to come back and I have
one in my office and I go to I go to two
different places he's my son headphones
would you listen just the speakers when
I listen in the office I put them on
with the speakers at the office it's
when I listen to it at home I got the
headphones it's um it's a different
experience right you're like you're
sitting down like you're watching a show
almost to think about music when I'm
streaming it as I'm almost always doing
something I'm very rarely just listening
to music I'm always listening to music
while I'm driving or listen to music
while I'm working out or wild flying I
don't hardly ever just listen to music
sit down but when you have an album when
you have a record player I think that
the it would definitely make you more
inclined to treat it like an event you
know just have a cup of coffee smoke a
joint sit on the couch just listen to it
just listen to it listen to some bars
you know listen I get anxiety about 20
to 8:00 every night 22 8:20 date right
around that same time yeah because for
years that's when I was thinking about
when I was on the score coke so till
this day that's the PTSD I got that at
7:30 I start giving Zionists or getting
itchy I really want intended to do was
to maybe lower jujitsu it but sounds
like wash you know my boy just got a
5:30 class I've been trying to make him
for three weeks 5:30 it's just rough I'm
at 10 o'clock in the morning type of guy
yeah well the latest
ice to always take 8:30 class at night
that's that's that's at this age yeah it
was hard to go on it was hard to go on
after on stage afterwards - that was no
no I like I don't mind all that it's
just gonna have a rolling and everything
- kid what you're not [ __ ] killing
yourself for an hour and I have you
should you know you warm up and you
drill the technique and then you [ __ ]
you know for me I'd do three rolls and I
gotta go after that I'm just it's a
little demotion when I was training in
tenth planet all the time with Eddie's
nighttime class 8:30 class yeah it must
fill with murderers most it was it was
killer be killed and they need go all
nice guys so I don't want me no no
nobody they're just really good but you
would go from that and then go I'd go on
stage I feel spent sometimes I'd go on
stage afterwards I have flat sets
because I was just too tired I was just
to mail it out I'd you know I've been
spent 90 minutes with guys on your back
trying to strangle you and try to it's
just you get there like you you don't
have the same pop and you work out at
night still I'd like to work out about
all different hours of the day that's
what I like to do well I like to do me
who worked on at night all the time like
three days ago maybe what time late
10:30 I could do what people are asleep
that's what I like to do when people are
sleep I put fights on put fights on just
you know got all the [ __ ] there
kettlebells there I got a bar there got
chin-up bars we got you know things do
that glue paint glute-ham machinae do
sit ups off of that and back extent I
would just do like nine sets of
kettlebells like swings and leans couple
goblet squats
and I'd be happy like at 10:30 it says
it's a zone at 7 o'clock though 7:30 8
o'clock I got a rush but not it's not
really it's kind of exercise but I gotta
get out of the house so I usually go by
the office I'd do two bong hits I listen
to one side of it out
mmm I just pick them out so nice it's
comedy some nights it's [ __ ] rock
music and once the album is over I shut
it up with the album back on the cover
my get in the car I go I'm like nah
most of the nights I do that I really
don't have nothing to do so I got a
half-hour window but I put her in the
tub I leave by the time I come back
nobody knows not let me ask you this do
you when when you're writing comedy like
when you when you're working on bits are
you how much time you spend in offstage
and like how do you do it like are you
are you one of those guys that just has
an idea and you drive around I know a
lot of guys are looking like right and
[ __ ] down they just have an idea and
they just bounce it around while they're
driving around and then like maybe
they'll remember some bullet points or
they'll bounce it off a friend and then
they'll try to do it on stage how are
you doing it now because I'm very
serious about it it starts with a pad
and a piece of paper and pray to God
that that I could just remember the idea
to get it out of me at the Comedy Store
right I just want to get the idea let's
worry about the joke later mmm so that's
the first thing right get so you have a
premise so you get the structure of the
prep let me get this out I want to talk
about that that Netflix show don't [ __ ]
with cats I keep forgetting don't [ __ ]
with cats there's wires rule number one
that they told me when I moved from Cuba
through a rock to the cat woman and a
black guy go yo I'm [ __ ] with them
[ __ ] some dude on the internet
decided to [ __ ] with cats and have you
watched his doctor series no it's gonna
blow your mind it's gonna blow your mind
it's a Netflix that likes 10 episode
documentary that's something you go it's
called opiates what did you get me
involved
Jodie's it's called don't [ __ ] with
don't [ __ ] with cats
it's like three episodes I watched two
of them last night actually like a bit
yeah it's like remember the old school
Internet [ __ ] from the early 2000s where
there's weird [ __ ] online yeah people
were discovering who the [ __ ] was doing
some of that and like fall they fell
down some [ __ ] weird holes oh really
this is crazy [ __ ] yeah yeah disturbing
is [ __ ] is it three episodes because I
think that I have I believe so yeah
watch three yeah yeah I think it was
more it's called don't [ __ ] with cap
don't [ __ ] yeah
that's it that's it don't cuz this is
how the party starts oh my god
tremendous and you know what was on TV
last week the reason why I called you
but I didn't want to tell you until
afterward I wanted to talk to you about
on the show i Boyd made it come back he
ain't gonna lie he got another week and
a half left to live who Michael Bowden
made a comeback because of the abstain
family Michael badan badan yeah the
Epstein family yeah I'm just doing I did
okay that's my boy yeah boy survived
that show you and me both oh my god cuz
I should remember having conversations
about with you about saying you can't
come in a crime with that guy around
dogs too good because once he gets on it
the most memorable thing he ever busted
was you ready for this G he found they
found the torso in New Jersey belonged
to a woman the guy did a great job he
kind of waist he cut her arms her head
and he threw a whole body into the ocean
the Sharks got everything except the
torso torso just washed up in the
seaside I to some jersey short time you
remember this episode I'm kind of her
man and she [ __ ] had fake tits ah so
I had sort of a serial numbers from the
tits I found out who she was but none oh
it gets better
he went deep into the murky waters he
also went into his stomach and the food
that she had eaten admin process so
there were a certain clam it was a
certain type of clam that couldn't be
found it wasn't there
and it could either been Boston in New
Jersey I'm not putting the blame on
those right right I remember so he too
found out her whereabouts and he found
that he called like every restaurant on
that area to see who would have that
specific type of clam hmm and he [ __ ]
caught the killer because he paid for
when his credit card whoa
so he went and found that the specific
clam what restaurant in that area sold
it and that's what she had in her
stomach
they weren't cherry stones or the other
ones there were the other ones there was
the most horrific story from that one
one episode where they had this guy
believe he was a doctor and he was
infatuated with this woman who's his
patient and when she died he I think he
had married her one time down or
something like that he it's some kind of
relationship with her he'd dug up her
body and kept it in his house and it put
a tube where her vagina is so he could
still have sex with her and he was
buying cases and cases of perfume and I
think that's what tip people off this
guy was buying cases of perfume because
she was rotting in his bed so he would
cover her with perfume showy autopsy
autop HBO autopsy yeah
[ __ ] great show great show and they
would come on like at 1:00 so he studies
Jeffrey Epstein and he finds out that
there's breaks in jeffrey Epstein's neck
that is he's never seen ever in a
hanging
they only seen from strangulation only
see four murders you know they said that
he hung himself
yeah am i [ __ ] am I missing this
they're trying to find it's a four foot
wall yeah he threw himself against the
wall mm-hmm
really all right the the neck had blood
but the [ __ ] thing then that blood on
it it's such a horrible [ __ ] thing
yeah the cops the overtime they had been
working the tapes got shut off how about
the fact that they deleted the first
tapes oh so he went he had an original
attempt on his life and then they had a
second one and they they can't find the
tapes for the second one and then they
activated
leading the tapes in the first one I
mean this it's not 1930
it's 2020 if they can get away with that
in 2020 I mean I don't know how far
anyone's gonna track this down how far
like how many they are well the reason
why he got arrested in the first place
is because people did talk about it and
they did get motivated to do something
because they're like how does a guy get
arrested for having sex with underage
kids and then only get like 13 months
and then during that 13 months he had a
baby but basically he was like he just
had a return at night right he didn't he
he had the ability to travel and go
wherever he wanted at 16 hours like work
release for the day could go to his
office we do what he did literally all
you do is sleep there every night so was
it an inconvenience an inconvenience for
him and everybody's like what and then
when you start thinking about the
stories and the jet in the island and
all the craziness like this is not a
movie this is real this is not a movie
there was an island where an
intelligence agent would take scientists
and heads of state and they would bang
chicks that intelligence thing is I'll
just say strong rumor because it's only
been mentioned by a few people and like
that ABC report didn't mention it at all
maybe they left it out I don't think
they can prove it so when someone says
something and then that I mean is there
a recording of that guy saying who
remember the guy that said that he was
told that it wasn't that Epstein was
intelligence news above his pay grade
Acosta yes his name again
yeah I don't know though Alexander cut
to Jim we got fired though or he had to
resign after they went and looked into
this and you got mmm RIA rested I have
not seen bombshell
have you seen bombshell that's the new
shop please they're wrong she plays
megyn kelly right Roger Ailes
yeah and it's all about the the sexual
harassment and I was watching the ladies
watched it together the actual women
that were that lived it and then they
afterwards they talked about it they
talked about what was real and what was
not
real but one thing that was really laid
them stand in front of him and twirl
around so they could see their ass so he
could see their house and like so
imagine you're a woman you you get this
job you're gonna be an anchor like I'm
really excited to work for you mr. Ailes
thank you all right this one I want you
do I want to see your ass I want you to
spin around and so he I mean that's a
weird is that a real picture Photoshop
for press release doesn't look fake
doesn't look a fake picture they
probably weren't all next to each other
huh what is he making Kelly complain
about she was sexually harassed oh yeah
everybody was they're all box yeah yeah
yeah apparently this guy Roger that's
his name roger ailes right what they're
saying is that you know he would say I
want to see you naked I want to see you
in lingerie I want to see naked pictures
of you it's just a dirty old fat dude
who just harassed the [ __ ] out of all
the women that worked there and that was
how they did it is that in the movie
yeah that's in the movie
yeah that's John Lithgow right they put
him in a fat suit right they didn't make
him get that fat I don't think so that's
a lot of weight yeah that's some heart
attack [ __ ] he's a fairly healthy guy
but uh that guy's dead right didn't he
die I think Roger L died I'm pretty sure
look at him go back to those pictures go
back to images I mean look at that one
the one in the middle
look at the one in the middle up top
with his the red tie out yeah right
there look at that I mean if he was
alone with her what the [ __ ] do you
imagine you would say what kind of
creepy [ __ ] do you imagine that dude
would say women always think like a guy
like that that looks disgusting that you
would never have to look I would never
have sex with him he knows that the guy
that's that rich and that powerful like
n looks like that he doesn't even
probably know that he doesn't have any
game I think he probably thinks that he
has game he probably thinks this is a
part of why he became rich and famous in
the first place these powerful men
before
all this stuff went down these guys that
ran these gigantic companies and that's
just what they did so they all did and
they got away with it
everybody knew right I mean how many
companies are like here's the big
question how long has this been going on
how long have men and women even been
working together like that doesn't
Jordan Pearson talk about this that
hasn't really been that long like but
you know in the 1800's men and women
didn't work together in offices like
this I didn't watch Mad Men but in that
what that whole show is kind of about I
think I didn't want to either
secretaries wives and the husbands and
yeah it's real recent for people for men
and women to be alongside each other all
day that you don't even know each other
and you're in an office together
throughout all of human history when
people got together and work together
there were a tribe they were a community
wasn't strange random guys that just got
hired by [ __ ] HR to come down sit
next to you in your office and ask you
questions how you conduct yourself and
like I know everybody in those days work
with people they knew right like if you
were in a blacksmith's office like a
blacksmith's workshop everybody [ __ ]
knew everybody they work together
one of my nieces just had a go and she
got summoned to talk to somebody yes you
know where she went
she's going to medical school now but
where she's got a regular you know
pedigree degree couple weeks ago she had
a go she got a [ __ ] letter in the
mail and they asked her about this
teacher on what she thought she had a
spill her guts and they haven't gone
[ __ ] at this teacher fired
you know it wasn't doing anything sexual
was what he was saying same creepy
searching him oh he was 60 something you
know and it's probably doing his whole
life how to confront them and you know
well that's you have to think about
priests right they've get they're still
doing it right they still they still
keep getting caught but they've been
doing that their whole life and the
people before them did it to them and
there's generation after generation
after generation of child molester
priests it's
one of the craziest things that
Catholics just accept that people are
nothing because most Catholics are not
pedophiles most Catholics are good
people that want a bunch of great you
know great people to live together with
certain rules and they think if you do
abide by these rules then you're doing
the work of God but the people at the
top there's a certain percentage of them
I don't know what the number is that are
definitely pedophiles and it's a high
number in comparison to every other job
if 25% of dentists were pedophiles we
would all have rotten teeth you know I'm
saying
I mean think think about all the
different professions lawyers or 25% of
lawyers were pedophiles we like their
buildings on fire the [ __ ] are you
talking about but for some reason I
don't know what the percentage is I
don't think it's 25% of priests we think
it is here's the [ __ ] thing with the
priests thing that kills me the priest
thing works pretty much it was a no-no I
mean we're talking about the 60s and 70s
I did a Google search on the grammar
school I want to just a look just to
look at what the sacred art school for
boys and one there one there one night I
was high and I was just one on a Google
search and went out of foxhole and one
of the couple reddit pages of people
saying different things and you know
what I swear to god there was nothing
about Sacred Heart School for Boys and
that you couldn't find them
but I looked up a different church that
was close to my house and it was 200
cases well nobody gets prosecuted and
they move you to another Archdiocese and
you start your little charade again and
then when you start like say you [ __ ] up
for [ __ ] different states but let's
say you go from Jersey to Minneapolis to
San Diego then to Louisiana then they
ship you overseas
once too many letters start to come in
about this situation then they ship your
overseas and they'll put you at the
[ __ ] Vatican well that's what's got
me fired up I grew up in this then I get
molested as a kid no then a priest
bother me now
I wish I could sit here and tell you was
I an altar boy no I worked the bingo so
I didn't really have much contact with
the [ __ ] priest you know when I did
Vinny rent brands wrong we did the
fat-ass stress factory one of my friends
sat in the front row he was my neighbor
he lived two doors down next to us and
after the show we were laughing and we
were laughing about the pedophiles in
the neighborhood how we would torment
him like we knew there were PTO's we had
a guy that played two-hand touch with us
with no underwear on Puerto Rican Nelson
and then his lure was ice cream we
should take the ice cream and then we
tell me go [ __ ] himself [ __ ] you when I
going back to your partner will [ __ ]
kill you you know you knew they got
pointed out the story I tell about New
York about the [ __ ] the guy that used
to chase little kids and shied that
that's at your store it's not a joke
it's a joke on stage but that's a true
story you know who the kids the people
were in your neighborhood they've gotten
called out in the 70s and 80s you know
don't [ __ ] with that dude yeah you know
there's a there's a cop in my
neighborhood where I grew up and I just
found this out I just found this huh
that there's a cop in my name was I was
dear friends or that I grew up when he
had two younger brothers that were twins
one of the younger brothers went to jail
for murder he killed this [ __ ] gay
guy what just came out was that that gay
guy was molesting him he gave him a
summer job oh well he was in the eighth
grade and started molesting him and they
still reduced a sentence you know he
went back a murder there's an adult he
came back when they when he was 30
[ __ ] murder my giving him six years
for involuntary manslaughter he pleaded
it down but this is you know it's you
don't want to help me when it comes to
my dorm trust nobody and you said a joke
up on stage the one that I know it's not
a joke oh I'll keep shooting yeah I'm
gonna keep shooting and whoever your
mother your wife I'm going I'm going
that's why it's better that like Cuban
parent you can sleep over here we can
send them my kid nowhere
because this is how it starts you watch
never-never-land Norton okay never never
my hands this turn now what is it escape
from Neverland what are you talking
about
Hey bye yeah sukar it's Monday that's
something for the spirits I have to
light another joint not you my dear you
have to get another joint cuz I'm ready
to rock and roll
you got one of these blunt yeah I'll go
grab one hold on sorry about that for
children oh no I've experienced it
before no I've had a I had a one of
those whey protein I can't even I showed
you I'm sorry I was looking for a
percentage number I just trying to find
out the number of priests versus
accusations but Los Angeles it seems
like 10% of the priests maybe about 600
priests and I said at least 70 of them
or so I've been accused oh god damn it
that might be high I might be low I
don't know that's a lot if that's the
nationwide thing
it matches that's the same it's mirrored
or even worse well now the three billion
to them have you seen it running an ad
have you been molested by a Boy Scout or
a [ __ ] priest call this number it's
never too late
blah blah blah blah blah blah you know
now you got they paid out three billion
mm-hmm five hundred plus just in Los
Angeles oh my god ten years ago that was
ten years ago so they might it's just
crazy that no one ever says hey maybe
this isn't really what God wants maybe
you know I'm saying I mean the people
that are in the church the people that
are believers the people that love to
dress up nice and go and behave kind and
and and see all the people in the
community at the church there's a good
feeling that people get from going to
church but the fact that it's connected
to that is it's it's so insane that it's
still there
it's so insane that it hasn't been
rooted out that this is still a giant
problem and relatively few people are
going to jail like relatively few like
you know who they wanted but they wanted
that a Ratzinger that Pope Ratzinger
it's one of the reasons why he had to
step down and one of the reasons why he
stays in the Vatican I was reading some
article about them bringing up charges
crimes against humanity against him that
other countries wanted to do that
because this guy used to ship kids or he
used to ship priests to places where
they wouldn't get in trouble like yeah
this one guy was accused of molesting
boys and so he shipped him to this place
where he worked with dead deaf kids and
he molested over a hundred deaf kids
it's like what did you do like you
shipped a child molester to a bunch of
people that wouldn't be able to talk
about it well like she'd be able to get
away with it easier there if they settle
the case that means it doesn't get
prosecuted right so that's why they
won't go to jail is that why they
haven't gone to jail I don't understand
it these reports on why aren't they
going to jail and I like if you settle a
case you don't even call it like they
don't keep prosecuting I just I guess if
you make us like the person decides to
drop charges there was a guy Boston they
were gonna [ __ ] give a hundred
thousand to the jail there was some time
Boston I read about you using another
jail now I keep it simple I'm still a
Catholic I just don't go to church I
don't want to deal with none of those
people I don't want to deal with another
yeah and any religious level I don't
want to deal with them the problem is
whenever people get into a position
where everybody for the most part is
like humble around them and scared of
them and they have power like I remember
when my grandmother died we went to a
funeral and the guy couldn't remember
her name my grandmother's name was
Josephine he kept calling her Geraldine
and the priest who was delivering the
service we had to interrupt him say it's
Josephine and he was like annoyed that
they interrupt him was like yes
Josephine like he he changed the net
like he didn't even know her name
and when he's there to deliver this
God's message for the last you know last
time the family's gonna view the body he
there's no her name and when he was
corrected he was angry at us
like he had these Gin Blossoms all over
his face he's just some weird old guy
who got tricked and did this very
strange life and now it's at its end and
he's been living with robes on
supposedly being celibate his whole
[ __ ] life while people kiss his ass
and pretend to be something special
because he talks about the word of God
but you could just see in that one
moment where he wasn't even embarrassed
that he said the wrong name he was upset
that people were correcting him because
you don't correct priests so he's used
to that so there's no one checking him
there's no one checking them at all
everyone who goes there is in this state
of worship and they're the ones who
deliver the Word of God
dressed like wizards like they're the
only people in society that are allowed
to dress like wizards in modern American
society they dress like [ __ ] wizards
and we're like yeah that's how father
dresses father dresses like a wizard
like do you know people are gonna look
back at that and go why didn't they
think the outfits were weird why didn't
they think it was silly that this
pedophile dresses up like a wizard and
you're not supposed to say anything to
him what is that like what is what is
with the outfits the fact that all that
shit's still around like there's nowhere
in the Bible that says priests have to
dress like that no where there's no
where the whole thing is so bizarre it's
it's you're wearing stuff that made you
look like you were very special to
really poor people 500 years ago that's
what you're wearing you wearing stuff
that would impress people that didn't
know any better that probably couldn't
read and so before Martin Luther
translated these the the scriptures so
that people could read it like a
phonetic language before that people had
no idea what the priests were reading
they just relied on the priests they
relied on the priests to tell them what
the Word of God was but now something
they could read it for themselves and
Martin Luther was saying he should
probably interpret it yourself too and
they were like oh my god so I said where
are they view old enough to go to church
when it was still in Latin oh they would
say something
only be in latin until like 70s or 60 or
something really yeah I remember they
would say some things in Latin cuz I
remember I'd be five years old going
what in the [ __ ] are these peoples what
type of kid were you between the age of
five and ten were you aggressive were
you quiet
no I did much more introverted okay from
the ages of five and ten I went to the
white changes until I got hitting there
with a lunch box but I believed I really
did believe Joe I really did believe I
believe in God I believe that my father
was in heaven I believe that I polish it
yeah then I got introduced to Catholic
school and that just [ __ ] me I'm
completely because I believed but I
didn't believe on the tail end of it
it was supposed to be loving risë is non
smacking me why is this nun hitting he
would have [ __ ] rulings I am and then
I saw the anger in their heart and it
turned me off completely like I didn't
like it today I'm still a Catholic in
some boards yeah when my body goes I'd
like to go to a [ __ ] Church you know
right but I don't hold it I remember
selling cars and Boulder but a guy came
in and we started talking and he was 50
wasn't a good-looking guy look like that
[ __ ] guy am I just a year old chick
with him and obviously have to take him
on a demo right I figured out that he
could [ __ ] her and [ __ ]
no I realized that he was [ __ ] her
she was like his receptionist or
something okay but after when we got
back I also realized he was my
father-in-law friend oh so I asked my
father bother me he's and he's on the
board of the church rule is he's a great
man you know and I still remember him
this was Sacred Heart Church in Boulder
Colorado in fact that's the same church
the head of the football team went to
bill McCarthy and all that should I'd
see his [ __ ] family there and and it
all sit in the fund this [ __ ] scumbag
would sit in the second pew with his fat
[ __ ] ugly wife you know she had
ugliest [ __ ] wife in
[ __ ] Church they would hit her with
the net with that money that they would
just hit her with it like [ __ ] you just
ugly but the point was that I never
respected it that you cheated on your
wife but nothing in here right there
playing the [ __ ] I'm a good guy
that's a classic story you know the
classic stories the big one is the
anti-gay pastor that turns out to be gay
there's so many of them there's some it
wasn't there one where a guy got busted
on because he was trying to use an
Arby's card wasn't that the case that's
a common one the anti-gay pastor that
turns out to be people preach the word
of the Lord yes stay away from the Kay
folks Missouri church leader tried to
pay for sex on Grindr with Arby's card
[Laughter]
look it's a hustle that they got away
with probably forever there's they
probably hid like who they were and what
they were doing forever with this act
and this smoke screen and you could kind
of get away with it for a long time but
that you can't get away with that today
and if you're you know like why you so
aggressive in stay people can file what
they sent you to get anything yes gay
but they always they should take and
they take the Lord into you touch your
dick is what they do the people that
have been to those pray the gay away
camps this is the claim that like guys
were hugging them with full hard-ons
behind them telling them it's alright
that God loves them like this guy was
pressing his dick against this guy's
buttocks like they they made him sit
like almost in a rear-naked choke
position where the the guy who's the
counselors behind you with his dick
against your back like hey what are you
doing is this really God's plan there's
a South Park episode about this where
the gay weekend oh my god
it's called Cartman sucks it's from
season 11 episode 2 2007 perfect yeah
there's been a lot of those there's been
a lot of like real recounts you know
recounting where people went to those
camp
they're like oh my god everyone was gay
who like everyone was like even the
counselors the guys who were saying they
were gonna pray the gay away they were
just trying to [ __ ] you I don't know how
much [ __ ] they do or how much they
just hang onto you back with a hard-on
and pretend that nothing's going on I
don't know what really goes on but
whenever you got someone who's that
adamant about it
you got a wonder yeah anybody ever try
to make a move on you oh yeah when you
were a kid yeah couple times from five
to how old the the scariest one was when
I was 13 when I was 13 I was in Boston
one time it happened before but a
librarian saved me I was like eight I
was in San Francisco and I was really in
a monster books back then I was in the
monster movies and monster books and I
was looking at these books and this
creepy dude came over to me and he said
do you like monster books and I said
yeah and he said well I have monster
books in my car do you want to come see
him I said okay so I was 8 years old
that was dumb started walking behind him
and the librarian screams out Joseph you
get away from him he just got out of
jail I'm like oh my god and the guy ran
and I ran to the librarian and she
hugged me and I was crying it's very
scary I got a call with a guy who's
freezing huh bus wasn't common whoa had
the basketball I was that same Michaels
Jim I got County Boulevard next thing
you know [ __ ] there's no number one
bus I'm that [ __ ] that one happened
and below you know I pulls up you want a
ride yeah I get in there and I still
remember how he acted like from the
beginning from the minute I got in
something wasn't right as energy wasn't
right and he thought he had he thought
he had pray yeah we're on a stick he was
like we were we were 18 and we were
taking a girl back to our apartment you
know what kind of clumsy he was clumsy
I had the light he went for the boy he
liked playing basketball he went
football
they touch my dick like he slipped Oh
Kelly's facing you like it and I was
like do I [ __ ] like it and Joe open
the door hope it was like God opened the
[ __ ] door I just got out and ran Oh
he kept saying come back I was just
teasing you come on I'll give you a ride
I was already home I was over at the top
of shits and barking when I give a [ __ ]
but that was basic and I always think
about that like why didn't people
approach Brian I knew today looking back
I still remember three guys and my high
school teacher that would come on as a
basketball guru and I found that and I
always thought a little weird about him
I married you know and then years ago
somebody said yeah he was sucking [ __ ] I
had a guy slow playing me at a lake
there was a guy that used to run around
the lake and talk to us with more
efficient but probably like 13 me and my
friend Josh in particular we'd go this
one lake it was in our town and we'd
fish there all the time and this dude
would come by all the time and visit he
was always friendly started off real
normal what do you guys up to catches a
fish like southern accent seems I got an
old gentleman and then a couple of times
he came when it was just me
and then he just sat down next to me and
talked to me and I was naive I was 13 I
just thought he was a real nice guy
like almost like a older brother type
figure it's gonna give you a good advice
he talked about cool [ __ ] he was a
teacher he got kicked out of his
position for some unfair reason he
wouldn't really be specific about it but
he said you know they didn't like the
way he taught and so anyway this dude
just becomes my friend like nice and
slow nice and slow brings me lunch I
even went to his house once and then one
day I am fishing and he's drunk and he
tells me he loves me and I said I think
I said something I really like you too
he goes you know there there can't be
love without sex
and I remember thinking what whoa
like what did he just what happened
and then I might remember thinking what
a dummy I am
I thought this guy just liked me he was
I was his buddy
that he's gonna teach me things he just
likes teaching people it's just really
smart but I had my hand on a knife I had
a Swiss Army knife from them little red
plastic ones you know the ones with the
camel yeah they have all the kind of
[ __ ] and all I was thinking is I put it
in my hand in my pocket like I held on
to it and I remember thinking god damn
it I hope I don't have to [ __ ] try to
use this because I was thinking it's
like he was a big guy you know I was 13
I don't know what I weighed 120 pounds
or something I'm like [ __ ] this guy
might beat the [ __ ] out of me and raped
me here in the woods like he was bigger
than me and he was always jogging you
know it wasn't in bad shape
and he I told him get the [ __ ] away from
me and he told me to not be upset and
then I left I got away he didn't chase
me I you know he didn't want to be
violent he wanted to trick me into a
[ __ ] um he wanted II didn't want to
rape me he wanted to trick me into
[ __ ] him I got real lucky that that
was the case but then years later I got
a letter from I'm at my house that was
creepy because it showed up in the
mailbox like he had figured out where I
moved to and sent me a letter oh whoa
and it was like real like friendly and
professional like a real professor like
a scholar I don't even remember if you
ever apologized but it was real weird it
was like whoa I dodged that bullet
how many guys that are like that but
aren't nice they just want to get you
clothes and then rape you that's much
more likely probably that is some
horrific [ __ ] man the Puerto Rican
Nelson I went to his house that's a name
that's what we called him he was born
Rican and his name is Nelson they
believe I'm giving that terrorist say he
lived next to the old teen house but in
the back
and I think he raped guys with a black
dude like there was a black friend of
his that would come over there and then
they give you beer uh-huh and all that
[ __ ] so he took you in as you like [ __ ]
type the kid like you always think you
want to see some good [ __ ]
and then that's how it started then
they'll bring you over there you go in
and he'd start with the porn first whoo
yeah bring your buddies any time you
want
then it was a porn and they would get a
Snickle bags of weed he started with
I'll get you weed and then he introduced
our black friend tool and I said this
black friend just looked too [ __ ]
[ __ ] like his afro was cut weird he
had weird hair and I remember him
distinctively speaking about the Rock of
Gibraltar I had just come back from
Africa movie young kid it's like wow and
then once he showed us the porn it came
out like a week later somebody said bro
that dude is no good ask what's his name
he went over that he had man he asked
her fingers suck his dick so were like
what are we doing that we call the cops
or do we tell carmine we're like no
let's just play the guy cuz he was
selling us weed he was like a bartender
in the city it was so sweet and then he
pursued the porno thing with us he's
like you guys to understand you know and
then he talked us into he like I'm gonna
[ __ ] my girlfriend come over and listen
we would come over there at night and
listen that he would leave the window
open and it was his girlfriend and him
[ __ ] and she would be saying give it
to Kimmy milk
daddy daddy and we like get creeped out
right out there one day and then one day
we actually [ __ ] went back then
they'd be he got normal I think with the
misunderstanding with the one guy he got
normal like we somebody checked them and
he got normal and then like the next
summer wasn't he would come out and play
football with us with a robe Arlen no
underwear just his dick guy and we're
like what the [ __ ] is this guy though
like he went the desperate measures of
aversion and I think missus and Adi said
something to him you can't be doing that
around hand with you dick and he's like
no no I just want to get exercises
something like he told us something we
did and that was the end of that you
know what's the classic relationship the
classic relationship with with crazy old
gay guys is the crazy old gay guy in the
young guy that's having sex with them
for money right there's a lot of those
cases is that more accepted in the gay
community that is in the straight
community because like if a straight
community if a guy is paying a girl for
sex its prostitution and everybody's
upset but is that how it is in the gay
community like do guys give a [ __ ] like
how many gay prostitutes get arrested
is it even close to as many as straight
ones I got what assume ice I would
assume like no one's getting arrested
like is that how many gay prostitutes
get arrested I think they do you think
there's no but just less number so it's
probably how it courses a lot
you think there's less of them probably
less than overall process for the
numbers yeah we live in a place it's
made of dreams on people [ __ ] that
dreams don't do anything fun do anything
from Joe I mean look at all the
situations we've discussed just play
alone RV Erica Epstein Bikram you know
Marilyn Monroe that guy two weeks ago
that two people died of speed in this
house that [ __ ] nutcase that same guy
that's right
ed buck that more people died there no
I'm just finally Oh
oh my god it's such a shame that that's
what you do for a living this [ __ ] with
people's dreams
well I think that Ed Buck guys probably
had just a serious addict he's got some
money right you know taking him home was
God and shooting him up with drugs
drugs really you know when I first got
his a hot book was you'll never work in
this town again
hmm there was a hooker who [ __ ] did a
tell-all book about Don Henley calling
her up to a house and they had a bend
over
and Don Henley would snort coke off to
her [ __ ] whoo and then get up plug
him once and sit back down and just sit
there so you had to go to Don Henley's
house he has a fireplace for women he
would just say bend over naked god damn
don't snort coke get up [ __ ] you for a
minute and sit back down snore Marco you
know all those stories at different
movies I'd be [ __ ] like that
would you be disappointed if you lived
any other way I would think that if
you're living back then to rock star
back then like you almost were required
to do something ridiculous like
everybody was doing ridiculous [ __ ] like
no there was no like clean and sober
rock stars back then we're there like
that hadn't even happened yet where
people cleaned up right people clean up
regularly now it's a big part of society
like people improve how many people
cleaned up back in the day right like
artists artists that were like really
into drugs they just died yeah no Kurt
obviously a suicide or whatever
depending on which documentary was 1983
you know put 12 [ __ ] 12 feet pipe in
your truck the wiring screws and there
was just one [ __ ] drive around that
was 45 years old and his wife was 15
whoa and he would bring out at work with
her
Jesus she'd be in the front seat she did
not go to school do you wanna know
everybody knew he if you looked at him
you could tell he wasn't all there yes
and I'm a masculine once I just this to
your daughter it was that that's my wife
I go she's 15 14 he was you had a
parents older tell me oh Jesus Christ
I forget what his name was away he led
no he will live the Western yaki was a
white dude from West Nile but he that
you know but Don Johnson married Melanie
jumped Matt Melanie Griffith's before
she was 18
really yeah looking up she was nobody
said dick was that uh look at the other
boy look at you that dude they're gonna
throw him on the chair when they finish
with who are Kelly if you think how he
wine stands in trouble at least how he
got some Marvy ha ha ha we Harvey at
least he's got some money left
Arkel he's done and like we were [ __ ]
nobody said nothing our Kelly used bribe
to marry Aaliyah
when she was 15 charges say he bribed
government employee in 1994 so that he
could obtain a fake ID for the singer
Aaliyah mmm yeah this is 20-something
years ago right he's gonna they're gonna
throw him under the [ __ ] in jail
he was holding woman captive [ __ ] with
the hedge you're not allowed to talk to
your [ __ ] parents you know was it all
that age is it all like in the 15s
that's what he's into is that what yeah
yeah they've got the video of him
pissing on a chick which I never saw I
don't want to see it I mean I had no
[ __ ] desire to see that [ __ ] what do
you think that is you think he's
basically like like running well I was a
little bit of his last week and he comes
across to you he is professional is but
listen some people know wounded deal
when they see him and that's what these
woman is saying that his professional
his skill is the art of the wounded
woman and then he plays wounded but you
know who do you talk to him that within
the first day I'll tell you they got
sexually harassed not too many people so
as soon as he starts at that you start
with your story about your uncle and
he's gonna take care he's gonna do this
and this that's how he went in Oh
the stories that these woman is saying I
just
[ __ ] crazy like it's just other level
[ __ ] craziness my manipulation you
know it's just deep old-school pimping
me you and I want to see American pimp
yeah and we went to that barbecue place
you took me to a good barbecue place
next door with American papers that use
brothers just that mentality I was
spotting those type of woman's you know
it's [ __ ] up but it's horrible and I
feel terrible about it and it just makes
me feel sick hearing the story but what
makes me laugh is if we found out that
JLo had been capturing 15 year old boys
and pissing in their face we would think
it was hilarious
if JLo went to high school and she got
all these sophomores and she brought him
back to her place for a gangbang we
would think these kids had a good
[ __ ] time that is well it's it's one
of those big giant differences between
the way we feel about men and women this
r.kelly thing is horrible but it is it
is kind of funny that if our Kelly was
like a really beautiful woman and she
she was doing the exact same thing the
15 year old boys making them live with
her and eat her [ __ ] and she would say
it's hilarious we would just think it's
hilarious dollars doing it yeah
Madonna's doing it he does not read or
write exceedingly well except when it
comes to amazing musical tracks his his
turn he said okay he doesn't read or
write well that's sad
the whole thing set if it it is weird
our ideas of sex based on gender
it's [ __ ] very different very we feel
very different about that story there'll
be a hilarious story if there was some
big tittied freak singer who has their
little sex call and she brings fifteen
sixteen-year-old boys over we wouldn't
really we would be like wow but we
wouldn't feel like a crime got committed
were hypocrites because yes I make jokes
of it on Twitter I see it another 16
year old teacher sucks a dick you know
but then you think Jesus Christ I have a
daughter this swings both ways right
so we're hypocrites and we're hypocrites
on who we you know
for years we heard about Michael Jackson
there's people I'll look you in the
[ __ ] face and go Michael Jackson
never touch the kid yep
yeah we'll look you in the face today
and say Oh Jason didn't kill that [ __ ]
mmm there's people that are gonna think
what they think you're broken so yeah I
don't obviously have any idea what
happened with Michael Jackson but I
would assume that there was something
wrong just based on the way he behaved I
would say like what other things are
weird about the way you behave the way
you talk is weird like everything about
you it's like you're so so shattered by
this whole Fame thing and you're
constantly getting plastic surgery to
the point where nobody can even
recognize you anymore I mean we never
saw that before that's the first
superstar we ever saw that like
literally became a different human being
like changed his face changed his nose
changed his chin changed everything the
complexion of his skin the color resides
like everything just kept [ __ ] with
his face his nose would collapse and we
were all aware of it we're like whoa you
when you watch never Neverland I want
you to watch it alone I don't want you
to watch it from the perspective of what
you've seen as a comedian it alone was
it actually called escape from Neverland
whatever [ __ ] never never I don't know
Finding Neverland don't worry I'll take
the [ __ ] napkin you know I'm not a
pagan on the napkins bother no it
doesn't bother me know what I'm gonna
say to you that I definitely well when
you watch this movie you're gonna get it
the same way I got it the lucky thing is
that people like you and I didn't drink
the kool-aid you and I have been at the
store and you and I have had discussions
and you and I have seen it's 2020
whatever the [ __ ] it is I know you since
97 98 we've seen a thousand comics come
and go yeah
some of his addiction some of his this
lifestyle wasn't for them but there's a
percentage of them that one day you were
talking to them about writing jokes the
next day they were talking to you about
scripts and producing they just lost
their [ __ ]
my and drank the kool-aid and because
they drank the kool-aid now they come
back to calm me and it's been four years
that they've been playing their little
[ __ ] stupid charade mm-hmm and they
lost all the steam listening there's a
lot of guys who are promising comics who
wound up doing that and they when
they're bringing these scripts to Comedy
Central and all these different places
I'm executive producing this and that
and that and this and then it all dries
up and then they direct is not good
anymore so when you watch this never
Neverland you're gonna see people who
got caught up people who lived in the
same evalue man they michael jackson
came to your house and paid your bills
and said you know i'm gonna take you
guys on the road with me you're all
included it starts off with the room
down the hall and the next thing you
know he's in the room next to you no
there's no more rooms on levels in the
same hotel so you're in that hotel next
door to you but your son your daughter
really wants to sleep with Michael
Jackson's your own daddy oh because
you're getting thrown you know you
getting thrown money to go out to
dinners a limos picking up to go see you
too you're gonna leave your two
daughters with [ __ ] Michael Jack's
think I'll hold up this town is about
getting caught up
I'm sure Marilyn Monroe Lynn come to
this town thinking she was gonna be
sucking Kennedy's dick Sam Giancana's
dick and [ __ ] the baseball players
deck yeah you know they passed her
around she was sucking she was passing
mob information to the Kennedys and back
and forth did you ever think about
[ __ ] that yeah I mean I'm not Marilyn
Monroe yeah yeah what the [ __ ] I am
talking about one of them one of them
was [ __ ] Canada oh she did yeah
Marilyn Marilyn this town has you know
it's always been that way we were
talking about Fatty Arbuckle earlier
what we pick and choose you don't think
that nobody no Behav wines name nobody
know by Harvey Weinstein nobody knew
that's what you're telling me have you
seen the video or Ricky Gervais jokes
around about
being friends with Harvey Weinstein in
the last Golden Globes and then there's
a whole series of people thanking Harvey
getting up there and thanking Harvey all
these including people that have accused
him of things getting up there and
thanking them and talking about how they
wouldn't be here if it wasn't for Harvey
Weinstein I mean it's like [ __ ] 10
minutes long it's all these famous
people thanking Harvey or God lol and
everybody's laughing like people people
were just giving him so much praise all
these like super famous actors Daniel
day-lewis everybody you name it
everybody Faye Dunaway whoever they're
all up there thanking Harvey Weinstein
he's amazing Harvey you're incredible
it's it's great then it's crazy if you
stop and think about how recent that was
and nobody knows I don't think they knew
unless he did it to them what it was you
know I think there's there's a an
innocence to a lot of people's
perceptions about people like that is
that like both parties are in on it
right like the girl wants to go to him
because he is gonna offer her a role in
a movie and he wants the girl to come to
him because she's hot and he wants his
dick sucked and they both know it right
there's those cases but those are very
different than the ones where he holds a
girl down or he takes off his robe when
she expected it to be a real script and
those are very very different things and
I don't know if people knew about those
I think they thought it was more of the
former than the latter I think they
thought it was more like creepy deals he
made with actresses but kept his word
and they sucked his dick but then when
you get the other stories makes me go
okay it's probably because they knew but
the people around him knew he's a pig
but probably didn't know what the the
worst accusations were you know I just
didn't wanna know job that - that could
be a commit they know but they didn't
want to know I had to go to his parties
they had a heat of this meals they how
to attend this
functions but they didn't really pass a
line yeah there's those people too right
and then in the amazing movies too in it
in a way it's just as guilty if I tell
you right now I'm going to shoot Redman
and you sit here
I shoot red band you get prosecuted oh
that's right yeah you get an accessory
your knowledge so you know when one
Epstein or Weinstein or one of these
[ __ ] guys are doing what they were
doing you hadn't known I take you to a
bar with employment you look at me and
go do these guys don't right or wrong
true right I go to [ __ ] Dan Tana's to
eat and I see a guy I see a guy work and
a [ __ ] I see a chick work of a guy
for the small nickel I even heard the
guy look at him go 500 it was that first
row were you sitting there bars right
there about three four months ago must
have been you know it's it's this is it
yeah well remember when the guy from the
Clippers got in trouble what's that
guy's name the owner yeah what was his
name sterling sterling Donald Donald
sterling right when he got got recorded
saying the chick yeah it was a girl that
he was banging with this girl he had
bought her a penthouse
he bought a Ferrari bought her a Bentley
it's just and she was for him super hot
like look at her that is a pretty girl
and he's a disgusting looking old man
right so that was his uber side piece so
he would just buy her everything
but after a while she's like yo enough
yo pretty hot though and like that kind
of trash away now is that in me to
situation no that's listen that's it
that's was he was clear and she was
clear they were both doing it for very
specific reasons he bought her a bunch
of really nice [ __ ] and he was rich
and she was hot and that's is that her
now what's that the state of her face
like I started wearing if you wanna get
seen oh that was back in the day when
pepper Otzi yeah let me enjoy now let me
ask you let me ask you you bump into
this broad ah okay at the last or is it
a meat to situation if you don't listen
are you working I think they have to
come to you first
what if okay 500 fell on my pocket you
sucked me you know like right is this a
you soliciting prostitution are you
soliciting an agreement or is that a
meat to situation it's all the above I
think the only way people would be
comfortable with it and even then they
probably wouldn't like like if if you
believe in people's rights you have the
right to do anything well you also have
the right to be a ho if you wanted to be
oh so if the only way would ever be okay
is if she made it clear that she was
willing to have sex for money and this
was her choice she could do with her
body then people probably leave you
alone but even then they'd be mad at you
they'd be willing to pay for sex you
[ __ ] disgusting piece of [ __ ] you
know you're supposed to pretend that you
don't want to have sex with her and then
you wouldn't be willing to pay for it it
would only be okay in everybody's eyes
if it was the woman's choice but every
time we think about if you think about
sex for money everybody autumn at least
I do I automatically think about sex
trafficking which is like the worst
possible case scenario right if you go
to a prostitute that that prostitute is
that's that's a sex slave right that was
the thing that they got the craft guy
they were they were using a false
accusation against that guy that got
jerked off you know the guy who owned
the page yes yeah guys just trying to
get jerked off Jesus Christ leave him
alone his wife died a bunch of years ago
so he goes to this place
did just regular hookers they jerked him
off and then he got in real trouble and
they were saying they were trying to
connect him to like sex slavery we
turned out that wasn't the case these
are just massage ladies they tricked you
off like those are real good I'm all
over it
I'm sure in the valley all that whole
strip you gotta be careful what you walk
into
you gotta be careful the place I go to
which is [ __ ] tremendous look at this
I'm you know just to show you look at
that my punch card is full now alright
it's the whole foot spa I go in there
it's all guys and one chick and the
chick is built like me and if you need a
massage
they got like whatever down the street
they got they got all the to advise they
got all the time massage ty and what's
the other one that's big at Sioux no
it's it's it's a white new corporation
Massage Envy huh all those places on
this block listen you go give this
little Chinese chicken junk for the 40
spot and then give her a lay a $60 tip
on cuz it's 44 45 minutes I give her $60
tip she's on me for a now I leave there
[ __ ] dizzy well she's tremendous
tremendous they usually have the one
they have that they have a [ __ ]
happier I got turned on Fujitsu go they
do the elbow on your back and all the
stuff I got turned on to this by God
Alberto crying he goes bro you you want
the best massage in town I'll show you
and like I live right across the street
live right around the corner from I
could walk there if I want you going
there some nights I going on date night
with my wife we want a date and we would
take sweats and we switch there and we
go and they pull your things they
[ __ ] put your feet in the buckets
they rub you down they do your shoulders
your neck sometimes I had only one
people rub my feet I got that [ __ ]
fungi toenail you little [ __ ] Chinese
hands on my fungi don't know they just
let it die the [ __ ] people
oh no I said [ __ ] let me just go as
if you were patient zero what's that you
were patient zero if they're rubbing
your feet and then it spreads all these
people and they have Paul Tracy back
yeah yeah I'm the [ __ ]
I got the fun right so now I even got
the groove on to get a blow torched
really cuz you go up in the valley and
the lady comes she sticks a thing in the
email and they blow hot another lady
comes in and they got masks it's
hysterical and she comes in and would
blow it cold they're like Carol Burt
we're out there beat iPad mm-hmm and the
other chick comes with a blowtorch and
they try to blow the fungus away you
gotta smell that you gotta smell that oh
so I did like six appointments where
they tried to burn the fungus off oh my
god this won't work
the toenail was on fire no it spread to
the other one no so now I got the big
one and the one next to it lon
and here's the ugliest thing in the
world looks like one of those [ __ ]
hosts from an eagle Jitsu I try to hide
it with a bad thing but it cuts right
through the band-aid it's horrible I
don't know what else to do I have to
take a medication but I don't know if my
kidneys can handle it because the blood
pressure medication oh you can't you
have to take a fungi thing that zaps it
but I took one that I tried the zap and
it still didn't kill it is there
anything you could apply topically or
does it have to be a pill they talk I've
done everything I've done everything the
apple cinnamon cider Clorox I dip it in
I wrap it in a [ __ ] Cloris and it's
great because I cut it what the best
thing I do is I cut it like some nights
when I'm bored I got it and when I take
the grinder to it and I grind it into
like coke powder and it grinds down you
have to smell that powder to believe it
well it is so stinky and I just touching
on with Jesus Christ and I have to wipe
down the [ __ ] counter and throw it
away but I will grind those first two
toes it's like a [ __ ] thing
like like your standing your toes oh
yeah it's a sand that I got the extra
rock for like I had my wife go on Amazon
and get like the [ __ ] auto Bahamas
stone yeah yeah bodies and I just
[ __ ] sad that [ __ ] toenail down
I don't even know Jesus Christ I don't
know where I got it it's internal and
you know its internal yeah because
that's how the fungus is coming out of
you oh so it's in your body and then it
just comes out through your toes so it
can come out other spots yeah but I'm
not getting it on my nails and nothing
like that it's just on that one fungi
toenail what if it came out on your
balls no point we only want your wife to
suck your dick it's an ironic then that
sack is [ __ ] longer than that it's a
[ __ ] nightmare
I don't know how women could suck an old
man dick
does that look at my dick in the mirror
when I go like the Vegas they got those
good mirrors
when you get you're at home you look at
your different looks the way it does
everything cuz you're used to that
mirror right it's not that you going
away
you walk back your walk past [ __ ] on
a vacation or something when you're on
the road working you walk past a mirror
and it catches you like I'm getting a
little fat like the real hotel mirrors
don't [ __ ] around is that there's a lake
there but when you look at 56 my dick
has been through hell
it's got olders you haven't helped it
smells like Newark Staten Island it's
kind of like the pee is different I'm
you smell you pee lately I'm trying not
to open the old machida was saying drink
his beer give him a shot of might beat
this [ __ ] this will poison you
when I wake up in the morning that first
dose of P is the worst smelling thing in
the world before I go to bed I drink
water a little bit of Thai cherry juice
and I'd take a [ __ ] baby aspirin
because the high level after 50 is to
get the heart attack between 5:30 and 12
I was making a mistake and taking my
aspirin at 7:00 it's too late you gotta
ball it
if you take that before you go to sleep
it's better for you I gotta ask you this
before we stop doing this the before the
podcast we were talking about the
bedding line for this weekend right sir
for Connor and cowboy right and what we
saying what we saying about the
over-under you guys are both talking
about it you're talking about the
over-under it's like 1 1 & a half is the
oh yeah they're trying to get people to
better so what they're doing right now
is they what they did they did something
spectacular for starters when you gamble
you don't gamble on the venue have to
look at what happened a week before and
what's gonna happen the week after that
now is the prime time of you're a
gambler because you have college
basketball pro basketball
you got action every day [ __ ] this is
wrong this is when people whose houses
this time of the year is bad you got
football playoffs
tonight's the [ __ ] national game
that's big Johnson
dollars college football tonight's big
big big money fake so tonight's big and
then we have playoffs are on Saturday
correct sir sunday so we got Conor
McGregor so right now the [ __ ] ESPN
two-minute tape where they just showed
Conor tonight the UFC preview as at 8
o'clock to 6 and they'll show you both
training camps and other people on the
card or whatnot
everybody's forcing you to port that
Conor McGregor after this weekend nobody
not even our man Jaime had [ __ ] the
Tennessee Titans to beat Baltimore
nobody nobody nobody ever been their
mother but Baltimore no even John Rael
to said something the John rival to say
something it was like it wasn't gonna
happen Baltimore had been on a hot roll
Baltimore there was another upset to
Kansas City that beat the Texans right
here this late 2014 they were down 24
nothing when you pull up the UFC card
for this weekend so I could see who's on
the card that's right there's the okay
so what everybody's gonna be trying to
bet Cerrone well that what's the line
that's around right now so you could I
get what this is plus two sixty four
plus two sixteen over under one and a
half rounds mm-hmm but then I go over
one and a half what do I make I make a
little more money than that the over the
under would be the little bit plus the
plus 105 for under so that I guess the
money is on the over right now it's
minus 135 how can the [ __ ] money be
in the oval piece of light it's very
slight though okay look so this Diego
for Hara is the favorite over Anthony
Pettis mmm that's an interesting fight
right there for right there they know
something we don't know hmm that's
interesting
Diego is very good it's a very good
fighter but Holly Holm Rachael Penton
yeah that's good fight Holly Holmes
given right excuse me
she's a favorite Holly yeah yeah yeah
Rachel Pennington is tough man she's
very tough painting is one of those
chicks it like she's had some
last-second wins like against Ashlee
evans-smith one of the like wildest
endings in a female fight she gets her
in a bulldog choke and chokes are
unconscious with blood spraying out of
her forehead
it was a wild finish man see if he could
find that finish Ashlee evans-smith
Raquel Pennington finishes Ashlee
evans-smith so right now what does that
look like Donald Cerrone against Conor
what's the money looked like I don't
understand money like I don't know I
would I would be just talking out of my
have spent a hundred bucks on cowboy to
win and he wins the fight you'd get to
60 so you'd collect 360 and if you bet a
hundred on Conor you'd have to bet 320
bucks to win a hundred on Conor
all right minus 320 the only way you can
win this weekend is with Connor and you
see Connor go on and then knocking him
out in the first round in the under what
if Connor
if [ __ ] wrestles them and it goes five
rounds I don't see a lot of people
betting Connor in the over final looks
so good that people are expecting common
going that this is come right out this
is Raquel Penningtons fight
so just go to like towards the end of it
it was a wild fight then and Ashlee
evans-smith is the woman who beat Fallon
Fox the transgender fighter she stopped
her in her fight right before she came
to the UFC it was just a wild fight man
these girls were going to war and so at
the very last I mean I think it was like
the last second of the fight she's
locking her up in this bulldog choke and
this is why like a blood is spraying out
of her head oh they don't show the
finish
that's UFC it's sneaky like that they
don't even see the tap or the knockout
like I don't get it guys I work for you
I love you show everybody the choke why
are you hiding the choke anyway maybe
it's just a time constraint but she got
her in this bulldog choke blood is
squirting out of her head and then at
the end of the the buzzer she lets go
and the girls out cold and it was just
like whoa it was one of those fight just
whoa what's happening you like holy [ __ ]
you know you see something that's just
primal there's moments and fights that
are just primal you know it's sometimes
those moments are like they're almost
surreal like when Francis and gone to
knock down Alistair Overeem boom oh just
primal just what who cut his lip who
[ __ ] up oh Rosen strike oh my god
Rosen strikes now gonna fight Francis
Giardino Rosen strike and Francis and
Ghana where Columbus Ohio god damn
that's a crazy fight I almost wish more
people knew how tough Rosen strike is
you see the fight with Alistair Overeem
and you go well ouster was kind of out
pointing him and then he caught Alistair
slippin really with like 10 seconds left
to go in the fight and hit him with a
bomb and broke his lip open that's true
but he still absorbed everything that
Alistair threw at him did never look
like he gets shook at all we're talking
about a guy and Alistair who's knocked
out Junior dos Santos knocked out you
know it was the k1 grand prix champion
no tremendous really knocked out Todd
Duffee in prize [ __ ] knocked out our
boys riser he needed your boy there
[ __ ] the great white hope
you know what's his name
mark hunt you know he's great white hope
he's Australian Oh Brock Lesnar
raucous that's a perfect example of him
but meanwhile rosin strikes just walked
through all that and I'm not suggesting
that the the Alistar of today he's had a
long career that he's as as durable and
as big as he was when he fought Brock
Lesnar there's really two different guys
at this point but still Rosen strike
he's a [ __ ] beast he's so strong man
and he's got legit kickboxing skills
what do you see he can fight we can do
money this is what it seems to me it
seems to me that Conor McGregor has an
advantage in being able to close the
distance and maybe a speed advantage
this is a perceived thing based on
seeing them fight different people
cowboy when he's at his best is
remarkably well-rounded and I think he's
more well-rounded than Conor
I think cowboy has a lot of tools that
people forget about particularly his
takedowns are excellent cowboy can
submit the [ __ ] out of you he submits a
lot of people he's nasty off his back
he's got wicked triangles I could see if
this went to the ground
Connor getting submitted by cowboy in
the Triangle what I couldn't see is
cowboy getting submitted by Conor in a
triangle I could see I could see Cowboys
submitting Connor I would I don't think
it's impossible for Connor to submit
cowboy but I don't see it I think Connor
can win by knockout yes he's very fast
yes his left hand is a [ __ ] piston
and he's sneaky and he's got nasty
uppercuts and he's got a killer instinct
when he has you heard he [ __ ] bombs
on you and the idea of the Eddie Alvarez
fight is the best example that Eddie
Alvarez was a world-class fighter and
Conor McGregor took it to him like no
one has ever done in his career tuned
him up made him look like he had no
business in the cage with them now for
Eddie he said like he just fought about
fight and I believe I'm in the eighties
a world-class fighter but the point is
in in go time Conor McGregor handles
as better as much or better as good as
well or better than anyone who's ever
lived he handles pressure so well kiss
his Floyd Mayweather with an uppercut in
a fight where he's so outclassed he has
zero boxing matches and he's fighting
the greatest boxer of all time in one of
the biggest pay-per-view cards ever it's
nuts right so he can handle pressure he
lost that fight because Floyd's a way
better boxer but he handled the pressure
pressure against Aldo talked so much
[ __ ] for a year going on tour together
tearing pictures of him stealing his
belt gets in front of him flatlines I'm
in 13 seconds perfect punch perfect
execution like it measures him with one
left hand before that steps back he
dives in with the lab bang catches him
coming in it's perfect under pressure
he's not the kind of grappler that
nurmagomedov is he's not in that
category have pressure on this fight oh
he's got so much pressure he fought he
fought the guy who everyone's terrified
of and at least he made it into the
fourth round right was in the fourth
round submission yeah and he probably
wasn't really prepared for that fight
you think about how much time he'd been
off of MMA how much time he'd be working
on you know just boxing and then
spending all that money because he made
like a hundred million dollars the
question for me is who is Conor right
now is Conor McGregor the same guy that
knocked out Boston Dustin Poirier when
he was a savage is he the same guy that
knocked out Diego Brandao is he is he
the same guy that knocked out Jose Aldo
is he the same guy who knocked out Eddie
Alvarez or is he just some new thing cuz
all this money and all this Fame and all
this attention he likes to party and I
what does he know if he's the same guy
and physically there should be no reason
why he isn't he hasn't taken any
terrible beatings even the number
comment' off fight he stopped him with a
choke if he is the same guy and he
decides he wants to let the [ __ ]
world know that he can still do it and
who gives a [ __ ] how much money he has
in the bank he wants to let the world
know he's here to [ __ ] people up and
he's here to reclaim his crown if he
goes into the fight with that attitude
I mean we could certainly see a
resurgence the question has always been
whether or not a rich man has the
motivation to work like a poor man and
he's a very rich man
we don't know everybody's different
mayweather fought hard to the day he
died or he excuse me to the day he
retired and Mayweather when he was
during his career it was rich like from
like a couple years and he was rich he
was rich so he was always rich and still
fought like the best of the world and
still trained like you have to train to
be the best what type of gaps was he
taking him between fights guys this has
been a long gap before no my god it's
not fair yeah before no mega mega wolf
it was a long gap you know this is true
the game has evolved a lot hmm you know
you know in a real world I can get what
you heard me telling Jamie was basically
this in a real world you know sir wrong
what's he done in the last five fights
around he's gay he's had some ups and
downs ups and glossa kg lost to Maz
Vidal lost real bad - Darren tell the
Dare until one was a battle so how do
the last five fights he's two and three
is where you tell was lost to Tony
Ferguson beat al Iaquinta though and
looked real [ __ ] good doing it so
he's lost to the gauge he fight and he
beat Mike Perry which was a really good
fight for him because Mike Perry is a
big scary guy throws bombs so he beat
him lost to Leon Edwards I think he was
sick coming into that fight but you know
lost either way and beat Yancy Medeiros
in a while Rama is saying that in a real
world he should take em out people look
at him
I don't think this is gonna be that easy
of a fight I like it I like the over I
love the over I don't I can't pick a
side yet yeah but I love the over I
could see everybody betting McGregor the
wooden round one and something crazy
happened I mean in a perfect world you
know
his chin has been a little suspect
lately Donald I don't know I don't think
so I think he's just been fighting
werewolves has been fighting the the
toughest guys in the world look
everybody's chin suspect if Darren tail
is smashing your [ __ ] nose open with
an elbow that dudes an animal and he's
big as [ __ ] when Darren tail fought
cowboy he's so much bigger than him
there was the difference between a
really big welterweight and a guy who
came up from lightweight Darren tails a
giant dude I mean his nicknames the
gorilla so here we go yeah he beat
Iaquinta he beat alexander hernandez
that was a fantastic fight that was a
fantastic fight because right this kid
Hernandez is a young tough guy was
talking mad [ __ ] but there's a giant
difference between no disrespect to
Hernandez and a Conor McGregor yes
Conor McGregor is used to those bright
lights man he shines he shines in those
bright lights to me the question is
really just whether or not he has the
motivation to train and fight like a
[ __ ] madman again like he did when he
was younger when he was smashing people
and for cowboy it's whether or not he
can survive the early storm
I think getting his leg kicks working
would be very big because Conor likes to
take that long stance Conor takes that
long stance and he fights right leg
forward
he fights southpaw and if Donald can
[ __ ] up that right leg he can figure out
a way to attack that right leg knees to
the body coming in he's got to avoid the
punches though yep he's up there with uh
who do I say he's with he's with Sergio
Pettis is coach up there he's training
yeah you should do Rufus Rufus sport if
he's a walking sport for this camp
they're probably working on a lot of
kickboxing but I guarantee woodlings
Woodley and Emma doing some wrestling
takedown because he knows that's where
the money literally has a big fight
coming up Willie's gonna fight Leon
Edwards and Leon Edwards is a dangerous
man it's like that's a that's a big
fight and Leon Edwards for whatever
reason is not known as much as he is
skillful you know he beat cowboy like
you said and he's the guy that got in
that crazy brawl with Maas Vidal
backstage Bosma doll hit with your
two-piece in the soda but that's that
guy's a tough tough tough guy super
highly skilled guy and Leon Edwards
and tyron woodley that's a very
high-stakes fight that a lot of people
aren't talking about like that's the
fight for the number one contender
because if tyrant emerged or if Leon
emerges and it's and it's a big fight
and it the fight goes well that person
is almost certainly at least considered
other than Mozgov doll who's the fan
favorite and then the rematch those are
those are the two possibilities the read
the rematch with Kobe a new smart other
than that you want to see you want to
see the winner of tyron woodley in Leon
Edwards it just makes sense it make
sense that that would be the next one or
MOSFET all those those that's how I
would look at it I would look at it that
way I would look at it like there's
there's a lot of options there's a lot
of options for that division and now
Connors talking about fighting us Mon
that would be bonkers
so if Connor beats cowboy and decides he
feels great at this weight he feels
confident now and dedicated he wants to
make a run at the [ __ ] champ there is
a big size difference which in Vaughn
and Connor who's Mon is a big person
he's got a thick around those 170 guys a
big that big Kobe's a big fella dead
Colby's a big Feldman's Big Show is
[ __ ] Mazda without big 1:7 yep it's
somebody else at 170 that's deceiving
his [ __ ] - I think Mazda I was in the
sweet spot he's not too big where I said
to kill himself to make the way but he's
he could obviously knock out
welterweight it's easily he's knocked
out a lot of welterweights
I mean the the Ben Askren one is [ __ ]
preposterous but of course just even the
beating that he's putting on Nate Diaz
Maz Woodall can [ __ ] people up at 170 I
mean I think him vs Conor would be
insane you [ __ ] me up dawg
you [ __ ] me up by not bringing back
the ran with you that boy that you were
telling me this I got Duran I'm gonna
put him up at the compound for a week
you know I went down a foxhole of his
fights oh he was amazing a lot of month
ago just that whole era yeah I've been
turning people on just tell that hold I
really a dad was we're talking my mom
so because I got pissed off with that
[ __ ] Vikram thing because he said he
came to the United States on the
pretension that he had won three
national yoga competitions in India and
I'm not that stupid I grew up on Wide
World of Sports we learned everything I
don't want world sports
I saw a dude catch a bullet with his
mouth on Aaron bankses Parliament Aaron
banks karate tournament yeah really in
New York City we caught a bull with his
teeth Aaron bankfull higher there was a
dude who that's what he was known for
it's on YouTube is that real Joey he did
they put a glass in front of the guy the
bullet goes through the glass - he put a
special mouthpiece on and they shoot and
then look how close was the glass watch
let me go pee real quick okay play that
for me give me some volume okay so it's
just music that's right so his name is
Ralph can I see it well this is
supposedly the video I thought what's
happening here maybe not
I just fries Jonah in slow-mo but
there's got to be like someone who
Snopes is this
I believe Penn & Teller do it now they
do it yeah they catch a bullet in their
teeth huh well Penn would be the first
one to tell you it's [ __ ] I mean
that's a hit half of their stick I
should probably get him back in here
have him explain how the [ __ ] something
catches a bullet in their teeth there's
no [ __ ] might not be the way to do
it but there's a way to do it that's
safer then there's shooting a gun at
your teeth I think I don't think they
shoot a gun at your teeth because I
don't think you could do that a whole
lot of times see if a guy's doing that
it's not he's doing it I think I can do
it dad okay give it a shot son now he's
done it before right he's doing this
bullet thing in front of people I would
assume that's not the first and only
time just catching a bullet his teeth
David Blaine did it - right but you
listen to me yeah that means you have to
practice how many times you let it do to
shoot you in the face
how are you practicing that that's not
real David Blaine
with a metal cup in his mouth Wow so the
metal cup caught the bullet another guy
wore I think this guy that's Joey watch
- had steel dentures Oh God even if you
had steel dentures I'm gonna shoot you
in the face and you got to make sure
that they don't hit your lips do you
know how hard it is and not hit someone
how close do you have to be do you wear
your with a pistol is that what they
using you can absolutely sure 357 oh
Jesus
there's no way that can't be real one
person died doing it
of course they shoot ling-su the most
famous person to die were doing the
trick always performs silently because
he apparently spoke no English Heath
when his final performance of the trick
went wrong and he was accidentally shot
in the chest exclaimed in perfect
English oh my god something's happened
lower the curtain at his autopsy it was
discovered that he was not Chinese but
an American named William Robinson but
that's a story for another day his scam
was he let people shoot him and he catch
the bullet in his teeth and his name is
Chung Ling soo and he pretended he was
Chinese but then he accidentally got
shot in the chest - got it and shoot him
in the mouth shot him in the chest
instead and he as he dropped down he
said oh my god something's happened
lower the curtain in perfect English so
the autopsy revealed that he was not
Chinese but an American named William
Robinson can't do that today cultural
appropriation but even back then that's
a hilarious way to die was just one of
the guys that was catching bullets with
his ass it was a couple of [ __ ]
lunatic so that's how I know I grew up
on Wild Bill the sports they showed you
everything but I got caught in a foxhole
they had Hagler tackling the Rabi ooh
Maccabi was amazed death because in
those days they used to do a
pay-per-view on Saturday and then you
had a wait a week yeah first Saturday
Sunday Sal no next next out the
following Saturday be on white rule of
sports if you can hold on but I still
remember dog being a [ __ ] kid on a
Saturday
and watching doom come Kim and Mancini
[ __ ] out of each other because that
was live on was Lobby seen Barbara
absolutely you know cook him that was
the reason why they changed the the
round number from 15 down to 12 after
that guy died was that again this was
out it looks like it's outside doesn't
it yeah it is outside outside yeah
that's crazy
Tim Ron you this had a January or
February of 83 dude this is a crazy
November 18 to like two months before
that November of 82 Mancini was an
animal
remember we fought Alexis argüello I
think that's this right here says he huh
the Korean guy do cuddle King God rest
his soul wrote on a piece of wood before
you went out to fight and kill or be
killed
yeah that guy was a tough [ __ ]
ray boom-boom Mancini
but what tough [ __ ] this was
1979 he was 21 years old is this a duck
who Kim fight so imagine he killed
somebody when he was 21 years old in a
fight that is hardcore man
probably both things and then also
probably probably how to make weight a
lot of deaths in boxing apparently
happened in the lower weight classes and
one of the reasons is that when these
guys actually enter into fights a lot of
times they're still dehydrated they
would dehydrate them selves pretty bad
in the weigh-ins to get to whatever
weight class it was like 134 but he
probably weighs you know 134 out of
quarters what he waited and he probably
walks around like 150 ish or something
like that and they dehydrate themselves
it's very difficult to rehydrate the
brain apparently it's not as quick and
easy as it is rehydrating the body and
even that takes some time so most of the
deaths in boxing have occurred most of
them is still very dangerous even for
the heavyweight division there was a guy
who went into a coma Russian guy in a
fight a few years back but in the
lighter weight divisions they think it's
generally when people get
more more more likely to die from fights
and they think it might have something
to do with cutting weight but it's also
like you know really skillful people
punch each other in the head the general
mcclellan fight is a good example that
they always point to because Gerald
McClellan who was just a straight-up
murderer when he was a light heavyweight
really struggled to make weight man real
bad and in one fight with Nigel Benn
Nigel Benn got off the deck and it
looked like he was out and made it back
into the ring fought his ass off and
then started taking it to Gerald but
this don't come come right here again
yeah and that was the end of the fight
after ray Mancini stopped him
everybody's all happy within the guy
slides into a coma mines up dying see
he's sitting there like so he's he's
really battered they think again I think
it might have something to do with
cutting weight it's a [ __ ] horrible
horrible way to go man but kill or be
killed that's what he signed up for
actually wrote before yeah I mean he
fought that way too you know what I saw
recently there's one of the wildest
fights Roberto Duran in Sugar Ray
Leonard one holy [ __ ] is it Wow oh my
god that's watched run right see ya the
run Toronto was the first one Louisiana
was the second
montreal montreal yeah that's a good one
what Montreal was the first one yeah
yeah gods are really good god damn it
was gots a really good one it was cold
icy crazy for Pipino Cuevas they're
crazy fights on that these guys were so
fast
both Leonard and Duran were so fast back
then and Leonard was just I mean he was
America's darling Olympic gold medalist
handsome sweetheart of a guy and Roberto
Duran was a straight up savage who was
sponsored by a cigarette company look at
that he's got a cigarette company logo
on its back that was a cigarette company
wasn't it looks like my bro I think he
had a cigarette company sponsor him well
either way maybe maybe it was just a
design he was a monster and he just
jumped on top of Sugar Ray Leonard
wouldn't let him breathe and sugar a
decided to try to fight his fight
squirt up to the fight squirt up a
little to fight Sugar Ray just decided
to try to engage him like up close like
this so they fought these kind of fights
like this in the clinch total [ __ ]
chaos kind of fighting which favors
Duran you know Duran was just a lovely
animal love that [ __ ]
so but see how he's wrestling with him
and [ __ ] under Kunder hooking him and
pushing him against the ring staying in
his face he's not giving him any chance
to move and in the rematch
obviously Sugar Ray fought a totally
different fight and got Roberto Duran to
quit but it was an amazing fight and
historically like one of the greatest
boxing matches ever just chaos as Sugar
Ray Leonard taking a chance and you know
his ego probably got the better of him
said I'm gonna beat you at your own game
or try to it and Duran just stuck to him
like glue and just ripped out his body
and stayed on him and then after it's
over dirt sure Duran still pushed him
away he's like get the [ __ ] away from me
like after the fight was over Duran was
still mad at him bad movement it was a
Montreal it was in Calabi cuz a couple
days before the fight Duran bumped into
it Sugar Ray Leonard and Sugar Ray being
a nice guy that he is had his wife with
him and his kids and he goes come on
let's go over and say hello to Bernie
was Roberto Costa and Roberto's like get
the [ __ ] out of my face before I [ __ ]
your wife in the ass read the book or
the book I can't believe it read the
book I'd let enter it got into Sugar
Ray's head so badly that that was how he
beat him he said that to him I'm gonna
[ __ ] your wife in the ass
see ya look he comes running back out of
my pushes and watch this look at the
[ __ ] away from me
animal still screaming at him [ __ ] you
screaming at him after a war
Duran beat him Duran was a monster he
was so angry look at him bro even after
all that fighting still insane finger
rocking savage he was an intelligent
savage like a savage technician you know
his boxing was soap
beautiful Duran was like he was he just
knew how to nullify you take away out
and put his will on you man
animal all right leave still not gotta
wrap this up Joey I got another podcast
together I love you brother
I love you very much I won't see you
this week what I'm gonna see you again
Tuesday come on I know I'm gonna be at
Sam tripley's thing tomorrow I'll be a
prophet 10:30 oh yeah okay Tabernacle
next week Oh oh [ __ ] Atlanta out of this
why did the special [ __ ] don't bring the
showers yeah yeah I love you having I
love you too Missy because you make the
right choice tonight bye everybody
[Music]